This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively... 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much simpler for
本期节目由劳埃德商业银行赞助播出。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不纳税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰是一个永恒的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特大帝征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了……100%。是的，汤姆，那是一个巨大的变化，但现在我们又面临着另一项税务变革。这就是针对所得税的“税收数字化”计划的到来。如果你对此有任何顾虑，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，因为他们致力于让这一转变变得更加简单，
you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is, is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitize your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system.
他们为你提供了一款实用的、经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的会计工具，将帮助你符合所有税收数字化的要求。最棒的是，对于劳埃德商业账户客户来说，它是免费的。所以，当需要将你的所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，没有什么比这更能说明问题了。凯迪拉克傲歌（Optic）是2025年加拿大销量第一的豪华电动汽车。通过无缝的33英寸显示屏和沉浸式的19扬声器AKG环绕音响系统，找到你的节奏。
Demands Agility and Optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac Canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update. Introducing Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg, a new fit that moves with you. It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer.
它追求灵活性，而傲歌以精准的表现让每一次驾驶都非同凡响。让我们选择凯迪拉克。在CadillacCanada.ca了解更多。豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动（S&P Global Mobility）2025日历年加拿大新车总注册量，并采用了凯迪拉克的豪华定义。今年春天，牛仔裤变得更加柔软、轻盈。隆重推出Old Navy的垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤，这是一种随你而动的新版型。它拥有你想要夏天牛仔裤所具备的一切感觉。
Easy, breathable, and effortlessly cool. With a fit that creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price, moment. Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg. Hello everyone. So that was the National. anthem of Brazil, one of the great World Cup teams. And we haven't actually had any Brazilian history, I think, since the last World Cup. So it is great to have them back. And Brazil, of course,
轻松、透气，且毫不费力地展现酷感。这种版型营造出自然的动感，阔腿设计显得现代而不突兀。此外，还有那种标志性的“等等，这个价格？”的时刻。Old Navy垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤。大家好。刚才那是巴西的国歌，世界杯历史上最伟大的球队之一。我想自上一届世界杯以来，我们还没有聊过任何巴西历史。所以很高兴他们又回来了。当然，巴西，
more closely associated with the World Cup, perhaps than any other team. They've won it a record five times. And the team that won in 1970 in Mexico, the team with Pelle and everybody, often seen as the greatest national side of all time. Even though Dominic, I think World Cup history specialists generally agree that England would have won that tournament had the CIA not poisoned Gordon Banks, the England Whelkeeper. I don't think they do. I think they probably do. Anyway, that's by the bye. We lost to Brazil, as you were a call time in the groups.
也许比任何其他球队都更与世界杯紧密相连。他们曾创纪录地五次夺冠。而1970年在墨西哥夺冠的那支球队，拥有贝利和所有人的那支队伍，通常被视为史上最伟大的国家队。尽管多米尼克，我认为世界杯历史专家通常会同意，如果不是中情局毒害了英格兰门将戈登·班克斯，英格兰本可以赢得那届锦标赛。我不认为他们会这么想。我想他们大概会这么想。总之，那都是题外话。正如你所回忆的，我们在小组赛中输给了巴西。
Remember that game? I don't because I was only two at the time. Yeah. Anyway, enough about football. Let's move on to more important things, such. as Don Pedro the second, the last emperor of Brazil. And I mention him because he's very much a friend of the show, isn't he? He is. He ruled from 1831 to 1889. But that's a kind of peripheral detail. What matters about Don Pedro is that he has a sensational beard. He loves the library. He loves music. He loves scientific, kind of all kinds of stuff, particularly meteorite. Yeah, because he's sending, he was always sending people off on mad expeditions to recapture meteorites from the depths of the jungle and things. I think, that's what you want from a Brazilian emperor. Yeah. Well, we've got him back today.
还记得那场比赛吗？我不记得，因为那时我才两岁。好吧，关于足球的话题就到此为止。让我们转向更重要的事情，比如巴西末代皇帝佩德罗二世。我提到他，是因为他非常像是节目的老朋友，不是吗？确实。他从1831年统治到1889年。但这只是一个边缘细节。佩德罗最重要的是他有一把令人惊叹的胡子。他热爱图书馆。他热爱音乐。他热爱科学，各种各样的东西，尤其是陨石。是的，因为他总是派人去进行疯狂的探险，从丛林深处找回陨石之类的东西。我想，这就是你对一位巴西皇帝的期待。是的。好吧，我们今天把他请回来了。
Oh, brilliant. Yes. So hi, everybody. Our first foray into Brazilian history since the last World Cup. Last time, as Tom says, we did Don Pedro the Second. This time we're doing the anthem. And Don Pedro the second is returning. That's great to hear. So a cameo appearance. We've also got the first man to see the Southern Cross.
哦，太棒了。是的，大家好。这是我们自上一届世界杯以来首次涉足巴西历史。上次，正如汤姆所说，我们讲了佩德罗二世。这次我们讲国歌。而佩德罗二世又要回归了。很高兴听到这个消息。所以是一个客串演出。我们还有第一个看到南十字座的人。
It's only the first European to see the Southern Cross anyway. The Southern Cross is a star, isn't it? A constellation. It's a constellation. We have some great characters. We've got a Jewish, a half-colle. Jewish, half-creole pianist from New Orleans. And we have the Brazilian captain at the 1982 World Cup, who Tom, you will admire because he had the excellent name. Yeah, top philosopher. Socrates, exactly. We've gained one or two listeners since the 2022 World Cup. And since we haven't
当然，他只是第一个看到南十字座的欧洲人。南十字座是一颗恒星，对吧？是一个星座。是一个星座。我们有一些很棒的人物。我们有一位来自新奥尔良的犹太裔、半克里奥尔血统的钢琴家。我们还有1982年世界杯的巴西队长，汤姆，你会钦佩他的，因为他有一个绝妙的名字。是的，顶级哲学家。苏格拉底，没错。自2022年世界杯以来，我们增加了一两个听众。而且由于我们之前没有
done any Brazilian history before, and since Brazil's history is actually largely unknown outside Brazil, we should do a little bit of a sort of a panorama, a tour d'Orison. Brazil, of course, is one of the world's biggest countries. It's the fifth biggest in size. And the seventh in population. And it's presumably the country with the largest rainforest. Yeah, undoubtedly. But it's history, oddly, for such a vast country, is almost completely unknown outside the Portuguese-speaking world. So to give you a sense of Brazil's story, until the 16th century, you've got this vast forested landscape, tropical landscape, where you have about seven million indigenous people, semi-nomadic people, the Tupi, the Guarani and so on. Then in 1500, the first European
做过任何巴西历史，而且由于巴西的历史在巴西以外实际上几乎不为人知，我们应该做一个全景式的概述，一次“鸟瞰”。巴西当然是世界上最大的国家之一。它是面积第五大，人口第七大。而且它大概是拥有最大热带雨林的国家。是的，毫无疑问。但奇怪的是，对于这样一个广阔的国家，它的历史在葡萄牙语世界之外几乎完全不为人知。所以为了让你了解巴西的故事，直到16世纪，这里是一片广阔的森林景观，热带景观，大约有700万原住民，半游牧民族，图皮人、瓜拉尼人等等。然后在1500年，第一支欧洲
fleet arrives under the Portuguese nobleman, Pedro Alvarez Cabral. And Cabral called it the area that he found. He called it the island of the True Cross, the Ilya de Verro Cruz. Once they discovered it wasn't an island, they called it the Terra de Santa Cruz, the land of the Holy Cross. But within about a decade, so by the 1510s, people have started to call it the Terra de Brazil, and that's after the Brazil wood that they find there, which is a wood that gives you this red dye, this rich red dye.
舰队在葡萄牙贵族佩德罗·阿尔瓦雷斯·卡布拉尔的率领下抵达。卡布拉尔称他发现的这片区域为“真十字岛”（Ilya de Vera Cruz）。一旦他们发现它不是岛屿，他们就称之为“圣十字之地”（Terra de Santa Cruz）。但在十年之内，也就是到1510年代，人们开始称之为“巴西之地”（Terra de Brazil），这是以他们在那里发现的巴西红木命名的，这是一种能提供红色染料、浓郁红色染料的木材。
But if they hadn't had that rich red dye, they might have been called Vera Cruz. It would be. It would probably be called or Santa Cruz or something of that kind. Yeah, exactly. So under the Treaty of Tordesias, which we've talked about before, when we were doing episodes about the conquistadors, the new world is divided between Portugal and Spain. And because of miscalculations on the part of the Spanish,
但如果他们没有那种浓郁的红色染料，它可能就被称为“真十字”了。确实会。它可能会被称为“圣十字”或类似的名字。是的，没错。所以根据我们之前讨论过的《托尔德西里亚斯条约》，当我们做关于征服者的剧集时，新世界被葡萄牙和西班牙瓜分了。由于西班牙方面的误算，
they don't realize how far into the Atlantic, basically Brazil projects eastwards. And Brazil falls under the jurisdiction of Portugal. And this really is your classic example of what historians of imperialism called kind of extractive colonialism. So they treat Brazil, the Portuguese, as a massive cash cow. And they are using it for its natural resources of sugar, gold and coffee. There's an issue, isn't there? Because there aren't the kind of huge populations that are necessary to do this extraction. Not at all.
他们没有意识到巴西向东延伸到大西洋有多远。巴西落入了葡萄牙的管辖范围。这确实是帝国主义历史学家所称的“掠夺性殖民主义”的经典例子。所以葡萄牙人把巴西当作一头巨大的摇钱树。他们利用它的自然资源——糖、黄金和咖啡。这里有个问题，对吧？因为没有足够的人口来进行这种开采。完全没有。
A lot of the indigenous people, of course, die. They die of disease. Fast numbers of them die. And so the solution, as elsewhere in the new world, world, but on a much greater scale than anywhere else, is slavery. This is the defining institution of Brazilian history, much more so than the United States, where we often think about slavery, we think about the United States, but Brazil looms the much larger. So almost half of the West African slaves transported across the Atlantic ended up on Brazilian plantations. So we're talking about
当然，许多原住民死去了。他们死于疾病。大量的人死去了。所以解决方案，就像新世界的其他地方一样，但规模比任何其他地方都要大得多，那就是奴隶制。这是巴西历史的决定性制度，远甚于美国，我们通常想到奴隶制就会想到美国，但巴西的影响要大得多。所以几乎一半被运往大西洋的西非奴隶最终都落在了巴西的种植园里。所以我们谈论的是
4 to 5 million people. And Brazil was actually the last country in the Western Hemisphere to abolished slavery in 1888. And today, at least 60% of Brazilians, probably more, are descended from African slaves. There's a brilliant history, basically the only real, really good English language history of Brazil by Lila Schwartz and Eloisa Staling, which I think I mentioned in the Don Pedro the second episode four years ago. And in their book, they joke, I think it's quite a common joke in Brazil, that Brazil is the world's second largest African country after Nigeria. And Dominic, can I ask you? Yes. Imagine you're a slave being. taken across the Atlantic.
400到500万人。而且巴西实际上是西半球最后一个在1888年废除奴隶制的国家。今天，至少60%的巴西人，可能更多，是非洲奴隶的后裔。有一本很棒的历史书，基本上是唯一真正好的巴西英语历史书，由莉拉·施瓦茨和埃洛伊萨·斯塔林所著，我想我在四年前的佩德罗二世那一集中提到过。在他们的书中，他们开玩笑说，我想这在巴西是一个很常见的笑话，巴西是继尼日利亚之后世界第二大非洲国家。多米尼克，我可以问你吗？是的。想象一下你是一个被
Yeah. Would you rather go to the United States or Brazil? Where would be worse? I think no question you'd rather go to the United States. Slaver in Brazil is hell on earth. It's awful. And what makes it so hellish? It's extremely violent.
带过大西洋的奴隶。是的。你宁愿去美国还是巴西？哪里会更糟？我想毫无疑问你宁愿去美国。巴西的奴隶制是人间地狱。太可怕了。是什么让它如此地狱般？它极其暴力。
There's no abolitionist movement in Brazil or a very small abolitionist movement compared with that in the United States. It's much later. And is it also that the white exploitative class is much smaller relative to the number of slaves. So therefore they're more frightened. Exactly. More insecure. So even by the standards of the new world, slavery in Brazil is extraordinarily cruel.
巴西没有废奴运动，或者与美国相比，废奴运动非常微小。它发生得晚得多。而且是否也是因为白人剥削阶级相对于奴隶数量要小得多？所以他们更害怕。没错。更缺乏安全感。所以即使按照新世界的标准，巴西的奴隶制也极其残酷。
And actually, it's a great question. Where would you rather go? And then there's a very simple answer. Most people, the single thing you want to do as a human being is to prolong your own life. And in the United States, as a slave, you die at the age of 35. As a slave in Brazil, you die at the age of 25. So there's your answer. God.
事实上，这是一个很好的问题。你宁愿去哪里？然后有一个非常简单的答案。大多数人，作为一个人，你最想做的事情就是延长自己的生命。在美国，作为奴隶，你在35岁时死去。在巴西作为奴隶，你在25岁时死去。所以这就是你的答案。天哪。
And slave revolts, because it's very violent, because central authority is so weak, because institutions are so, cloning institutions are so fragile, slave revolts are much more common in Brazil. So you have gigantic slave uprisings in the 18th and 90th centuries, which then provoke violent repression in their turn. So in their book on Brazilian history, Schwartz and Stalin described the Brazilian plantations as, quote, hell on earth, a frenzy of cruelty, a world of violence rooted in the figure of the master and his supreme power under the law, the marks of which were constantly registered on the bodies of his slaves. Now, why do I say all this when we're talking about the National Anthem? Because the National Anthem never mentioned slavery at all, obviously.
还有奴隶起义，因为这里非常暴力，因为中央权威如此薄弱，因为殖民制度如此脆弱，奴隶起义在巴西要普遍得多。所以你在18世纪和19世纪有巨大的奴隶起义，这反过来又引发了暴力的镇压。因此，在他们关于巴西历史的书中，施瓦茨和斯塔林将巴西的种植园描述为“人间地狱，一场残酷的狂欢，一个植根于主人及其法律下至高权力的暴力世界，其痕迹不断地刻在奴隶的身体上”。现在，为什么我在谈论国歌时要说这些？因为国歌显然根本没有提到奴隶制。
It's not the kind of thing you would sing about, is it? No. The answer is that as we've discussed in previous episodes, Germany, the United States, the Dutch Republic, and so on. A national anthem tells a story about a country and about the sort of the idea of the nation as a united family. It's very difficult to do that in Brazil because there's a fundamental instability that runs right through Brazilian history. weak central authority, the legitimacy of authority was being questioned, a constant tension between the capital and the provinces, a sense that the next colossal rebellion is just around the corner. It's hard to tell a collective story about Brazil's history behind which everybody can unite.
这不是你会唱的那种东西，对吧？不。答案是，正如我们在之前的剧集中讨论过的，德国、美国、荷兰共和国等等。国歌讲述了一个关于国家的故事，以及关于作为一个团结家庭的民族理念。这在巴西很难做到，因为巴西历史中贯穿着一种根本性的不稳定。中央权威薄弱，权威的合法性受到质疑，首都和各省之间持续紧张，一种下一次巨大的叛乱即将来临的感觉。很难讲述一个关于巴西历史的集体故事，让每个人都能团结在它背后。
And that explains why, for so long, the national anthem didn't have any lyrics. Now, it wasn't a deliberate choice. It was because they couldn't actually agree on what story they were going to tell. I mean, I suppose if we think about so many of the anthems that we've done, the idea of kind of liberty and freedom is, I mean, a fairly common theme. And obviously, that's impossible, isn't it? In the context of Brazil. Well, you need an enemy often with an anthem. So for the Americans, it was the British.
这就解释了为什么国歌长期以来没有任何歌词。现在，这不是一个故意的选择。这是因为他们实际上无法就他们要讲述的故事达成一致。我的意思是，我想如果我们考虑我们做过的那么多国歌，那种关于自由和解放的理念，我的意思是，是一个相当普遍的主题。显然，这在巴西的背景下是不可能的，对吧？嗯，你通常需要一个敌人来唱国歌。所以对于美国人来说，是英国人。
For the Dutch, it was the Spanish. You know, even though their anthem is quite ambiguous about their relationship with Spanish. The Germans, it was actually the French. And for the British, it's the Spanish and the French. There's almost always an adversary. And in Brazil, as we'll come to, it is at first the Portuguese. So let's get to the story of why Brazil needs an anthem in the first place. So we start at the beginning of the 19th century.
对于荷兰人来说，是西班牙人。你知道，即使他们的国歌对他们与西班牙的关系相当模糊。德国人，实际上是法国人。而对于英国人来说，是西班牙人和法国人。几乎总有一个对手。而在巴西，正如我们将要谈到的，起初是葡萄牙人。所以让我们进入为什么巴西首先需要国歌的故事。所以我们从19世纪初开始。
So in 1808, the government general of Brazil, as it's called, is the biggest state in Portugal's colonial empire. It's got about two and a half million people. So it's slightly smaller than Portugal itself. And a third of those people are slaves. There are two big cities, Rio and Salvador. And there, the slave population is actually bigger, probably half in Rio, three quarters and Salvador. There's a sort of wild west vibe to these places. So people who visit, say, streets are pothole, they're full of rubbish, it's all very chaotic and very violence. And
所以1808年，所谓的巴西总督辖区是葡萄牙殖民帝国中最大的国家。它有大约250万人。所以它比葡萄牙本身稍微小一点。而这些人中有三分之一是奴隶。有两个大城市，里约和萨尔瓦多。在那里，奴隶人口实际上更多，在里约可能占一半，在萨尔瓦多占四分之三。这些地方有一种狂野西部的氛围。所以访问的人说，街道坑坑洼洼，到处都是垃圾，一切都非常混乱且充满暴力。而且
one British visitor called Rio, one of the dirtiest congregations of human beings under the sun. If you're a refined, elegant Portuguese courtier, Rio is basically the last place on the world that you would ever want to live. However, you are going to have to live there. Because in the summer of 1807, Napoleon Bonaparte had lost patience. with Portugal's refusal to join his continental system. So this is the blockade, the embargo against Britain to try and drive Britain out of the Napoleonic Wars. And the French and the Spanish in November 807 invaded Portugal
一位英国游客称里约是“太阳底下最肮脏的人类聚集地之一”。如果你是一位精致、优雅的葡萄牙朝臣，里约基本上是你这辈子最不想住的地方。然而，你将不得不住在那里。因为在1807年夏天，拿破仑·波拿巴失去了耐心，因为葡萄牙拒绝加入他的大陆体系。这就是针对英国的封锁和禁运，试图将英国赶出拿破仑战争。而法国人和西班牙人在1807年11月入侵了葡萄牙，
and they basically stormed towards Lisbon. By the time they got to Lisbon, they found that the entire Portuguese royal family, the whole of the court, most of the political elite, had gone. They had embarked on British ships under Sir Sidney Smith. We're talking about almost 15,000 people, and they had sailed off to Brazil. An absolutely unprecedented moment, you know, the entire court fleeing across the Atlantic. So it's a bit like the plans that were made to remove the British royal family in 1940.
他们基本上冲向了里斯本。当他们到达里斯本时，他们发现整个葡萄牙王室、整个宫廷、大部分政治精英都已经离开了。他们在西德尼·史密斯爵士的英国船只上登船。我们谈论的是近15000人，他们航行到了巴西。一个绝对前所未有的时刻，你知道，整个宫廷逃过大西洋。所以这有点像1940年撤离英国王室的计划。
To Canada. To Canada. In the US, exactly. Yeah. And chief among them are the queen of Portugal, Donna Maria, who is kind of out of public life. She's got massive depression and mental illness. And her son and regent, who is Joao and his son. Pedro. So three generations. And off they all go and they established their court in Rio and here they
去加拿大。去加拿大。在美国，没错。是的。其中最主要的是葡萄牙女王唐娜·玛丽亚，她基本上退出了公众生活。她患有严重的抑郁症和精神疾病。还有她的儿子和摄政王若昂，以及他的儿子佩德罗。所以是三代人。他们都走了，在里约建立了他们的宫廷，在这里
run their empire in exile. So this is the first time in history that an empire has been governed not from the metropolis but from a colony that is in both the western and the southern hemisphere. So it's a sort of really interesting kind of transfer of power from Europe to the Americas. Anyway, 1815, Napoleon's beaten at Waterloo, and a year later, Donna Maria, who is the sort of nominal queen of Portugal, dies. So now her son, Joao, is Dom Joao the sixth king of Portugal. But he's still in Brazil. And he's still in Brazil. He's still in Rio.
他们流亡统治着他们的帝国。所以这是历史上第一次一个帝国不是从大都市，而是从一个既在西半球又在南半球的殖民地进行统治。所以这是一个非常有趣的从欧洲到美洲的权力转移。总之，1815年，拿破仑在滑铁卢战败，一年后，作为葡萄牙名义女王的唐娜·玛丽亚去世了。所以现在她的儿子若昂是葡萄牙国王若昂六世。但他还在巴西。而且他还在巴西。他还在里约。
So Domzioao is a very shy man. He's very religious. He basically spends all his time listening to sacred music. So listening to anthems. Yeah, he listens to anthems, exactly. he's got constant panic attacks he's always depressed he wears the same coat all the time
所以若昂是一个非常害羞的人。他非常虔诚。他基本上把所有时间都花在听圣乐上。所以听国歌。是的，他听国歌，没错。他经常惊恐发作，他总是很沮丧，他总是穿着同一件外套，
even in bed he loves this coat I mean I've got to say he does not sign the count of man he could have taken on Napoleon no no he's done well getting out to Rio yeah and he is in no hurry to go back to Portugal if he went back to Lisbon the nobility the political elite
甚至在床上，他喜欢这件外套。我的意思是，我不得不说，他看起来不像个男人，他本可以对付拿破仑的。不，不，他逃到里约做得很好。是的，而且他不急于回到葡萄牙。如果他回到里斯本，贵族、政治精英、
political reformers liberal constitutionalists would just be badgering him the whole time but what about all the potholes in Rio and the rubbish he doesn't mind the potholes because Rio also has lovely birds and he's a big nature lover. So he goes on expeditions to the countryside to look at the nature, nice trees and plants, tropical shrubs. Is he a fan of volleyball? Exactly. I don't think they're doing volleyball at this point. So at the end of 1815, he elevates Brazil to the same level as Portugal. So he now rules
政治改革者、自由宪政主义者会一直纠缠他。但里约的那些坑坑洼洼和垃圾怎么办？他不介意坑坑洼洼，因为里约也有可爱的鸟儿，他是一个大自然爱好者。所以他去乡下探险看大自然，漂亮的树木和植物，热带灌木。他是排球爱好者吗？没错。我不认为他们当时在打排球。所以1815年底，他将巴西提升到与葡萄牙相同的水平。所以他现在统治着
the kingdom called the United Kingdom of Portugal, Brazil and the Al-Garves. I don't know exactly why the Al-Gaurs are plural. Maybe listeners can explain that to me. Now, back in Portugal, the sort of liberal elites in Porto and Lisbon understandably hate this. They like, why on earth have we ceded first place? Why I was sharing it with these upstarts in Brazil? Also, Portugal is in a massive mess after the Napoleonic Wars. Their harvests have failed. Their economies in ruins.
一个名为“葡萄牙、巴西和阿尔加维联合王国”的王国。我不知道为什么阿尔加维是复数。也许听众可以向我解释一下。现在，回到葡萄牙，波尔图和里斯本的自由派精英们理所当然地讨厌这一点。他们想，我们为什么要把第一的位置让出去？为什么我要和巴西的这些暴发户分享？而且，葡萄牙在拿破仑战争后陷入了巨大的混乱。他们的收成失败了。他们的经济陷入了废墟。
They're no longer really top dog in their own empire. They're very cross. And then spring of 1821, they sent Domzouaul an ultimatum. And they said, come back to Portugal or else, basically. And he said, oh, fine, very disconsolately. And before he left, he called in his 22-year-old son, Pedro. So this is the future Don Pedro the first. And he says to Pedro, I'd like you to stay in Rio.
他们不再是自己帝国中的老大。他们非常生气。然后在1821年春天，他们给若昂发出了最后通牒。他们说，回葡萄牙，否则……基本上。他说，哦，好吧，非常沮丧地。在他离开之前，他叫来了他22岁的儿子佩德罗。这就是未来的佩德罗一世。他对佩德罗说，我希望你留在里约。
You're going to be my regent in Brazil. Now, he and Pedro don't get on at all, but this is the only time they ever have any connection. Because Zhao says to Pedro, if Brazil breaks away, it would be better that it is by your hand than by the hand of some adventurer. Oh, essentially the king of Portugal and Brazil Yeah Is basically telling his own son to lead a secessionist movement Kind of, yeah That's unexpected
你将是我在巴西的摄政王。现在，他和佩德罗根本合不来，但这是他们唯一一次有联系。因为若昂对佩德罗说，如果巴西分裂出去，最好是由你的手，而不是由某个冒险家的手。哦，基本上葡萄牙和巴西的国王，是的，基本上是在告诉他自己的儿子去领导一场分裂运动。有点，是的。这出乎意料。
You could say he's being far-sighted That's another first for Portugal Yeah, he's being far-sighted He's basically saying Probably Brazil is going to try and break away I would like it to stay in the family If it looks like it's going to break away You'd be on the right side
你可以说他很有远见。那是葡萄牙的又一个第一。是的，他很有远见。他基本上是在说，巴西可能会试图分裂出去。我希望它能留在家族里。如果看起来它要分裂出去，你站在正确的一边，
So it would be a bit like The Prince Regent Being the governor of New York or something And leading the revolution George III being summoned back by angry mercantile elites in London and saying to the Prince Regent before he leaves, if the colonists refuse to pay their taxes,
那会有点像摄政王成为纽约的总督之类的，并领导革命。乔治三世被伦敦愤怒的商业精英召回，并在离开前对摄政王说，如果殖民者拒绝纳税，
put yourself on their side, and then it'll stay in the family. So an alternative history in which the first leader of the United States is the Prince Regent. What could have been? I mean, he's got his own teeth, which is something you can say for him. Yes, that's true.
站在他们那边，然后它就会留在家族里。所以这是一个替代历史，其中美国的第一任领导人是摄政王。本来会怎样？我的意思是，他有自己的牙齿，这是你可以对他说的。是的，那是真的。
So now we have a very strange situation where Zhu has gone back to Lisbon, but Pedro is the top dog in Rio. And Pedro is an interesting character. He's very intelligent. He's very well read. He loves all the new liberal ideas. He's been reading Voltaire.
所以现在我们有一个非常奇怪的情况，若昂回到了里斯本，但佩德罗是里约的老大。佩德罗是一个有趣的人物。他非常聪明。他博览群书。他热爱所有新的自由思想。他一直在读伏尔泰。
He's been reading Edmund Burke. He's also, you know, as is so often the way, spoiled, impulsive, erratic. But he's not hiding out in bed wearing a coat. No, he's not wearing his coat in bed. He's more proactive. He's a bit of a lecher, actually. He's a hit with the ladys. So his coat would not come in handy.
他一直在读埃德蒙·伯克。他也是，正如经常发生的那样，被宠坏了，冲动，反复无常。但他没有躲在床上穿着外套。不，他没有穿着外套在床上。他更积极主动。他其实是个好色之徒。他很受女士欢迎。所以他的外套派不上用场。
Because he's grown up and spent so much of his life in Rio, he cares much more about Brazil than he does about Portugal. And the local politicians recognize this and they say, well, if we work on this guy, we can use him as a figurehead to get independence. Who wants to be pushed around by a lot of people who make port and corks or whatever they're making back in Portugal? Who cares about them? We can pursue our own destiny. In December 1821, the Portuguese who have kind of got wind of all this, they asked Pedro to come back to Lisbon as well because they thought, you know, him staying in Brazil is just encouraging separatism. And then the Brazilians presented him with a petition signed by 8,000 people.
因为他在里约长大，度过了他生命中的大部分时间，他比关心葡萄牙更关心巴西。当地政客认识到了这一点，他们说，好吧，如果我们在这个人身上下功夫，我们可以利用他作为争取独立的傀儡。谁想被那些在葡萄牙制造波特酒和软木塞或无论他们在制造什么的人摆布？谁在乎他们？我们可以追求我们自己的命运。1821年12月，已经听到风声的葡萄牙人也要求佩德罗回到里斯本，因为他们认为，他留在巴西只会鼓励分裂主义。然后巴西人向他提交了一份由8000人签署的请愿书。
This is a very famous moment in Brazilian history, Tom. I'm sure you're over it. This was a reception at the Royal Palace in Brazil in January 1822. He gets given this petition. He's very touched and he says, as it is for the good of all and for the general happiness of the nation, I am ready. Tell the people I will stay.
这是巴西历史上一个非常著名的时刻，汤姆。我相信你很了解。这是1822年1月在巴西皇宫举行的招待会。他收到了这份请愿书。他非常感动，他说，为了所有人的利益和国家的普遍幸福，我准备好了。告诉人民，我会留下来。
Hurrah, hurrah. Everyone in Rio is very pleased. They can see what's coming. So eight months go by. And then on the 28th of August, 1522, a ship arrives in Rio from Lisbon. And the ship has a message. The Portuguese parliament, which is called the Kortesh, has ordered Pedro to come home immediately,
万岁，万岁。里约的每个人都非常高兴。他们能看出即将发生什么。所以八个月过去了。然后在1522年8月28日，一艘船从里斯本抵达里约。船上有一个信息。葡萄牙议会，也就是所谓的“科尔特斯”（Kortesh），命令佩德罗立即回家，
and they've accused his ministers in Brazil of treason. So the breach has come. The ministerial council in Rio send a messenger off to find Pedro. Pedro has gone off actually to visit Sao Paulo, and he's on his way back. So the messengers don't catch up with him until the morning of the 7th of September, 1822. Tom, the most consequential date in Brazilian history. Wow. So they find Pedro in a village outside Sao Paulo, not in very glamorous circumstances.
他们指控他在巴西的部长们叛国。所以决裂已经到来。里约的部长会议派出一名信使去寻找佩德罗。佩德罗实际上已经去访问圣保罗了，他正在回来的路上。所以信使直到1822年9月7日的早晨才追上他。汤姆，巴西历史上最重要的日期。哇。所以他们在圣保罗郊外的一个村庄找到了佩德罗，情况并不怎么光彩。
He's riding this sort of ragged, beaten down old horse. He's wearing a very plain, unadorned military uniform. He's recently drunk some dirty water and is suffering intense diarrhea. It's, what, two weeks since we had all that dysentery on Gallipoli? Yeah. Great to have dysentery back on the show. It's very Gallipoli. He keeps him to get off his horse and relieve himself. He cuts a terrible figure. Why? I mean, he's basically the ruler of Brazil. Why isn't he looking a bit more glamorous? Why hasn't he got trumpets and glamorous uniforms and things and an escort? Why is he just wandering around like Don Quixote?
他骑着一匹破烂、疲惫的老马。他穿着一件非常朴素、没有任何装饰的军装。他最近喝了一些脏水，正遭受严重的腹泻。这是，距离我们在加里波利经历所有那些痢疾已经两周了？是的。很高兴痢疾又回到了节目中。这非常加里波利。他不得不从马上下来解决问题。他看起来很糟糕。为什么？我的意思是，他基本上是巴西的统治者。为什么他看起来不那么光彩？为什么他没有小号、华丽的制服之类的东西和护卫？为什么他只是像堂吉诃德一样四处游荡？
To be honest, I think Brazil is a little bit more Wild West at this point. Okay. Than you're imagining. I think it's hard to wear gold braid and epaulettes when you are out in the jungle. Yeah, you're out in the badlands of Sao Paulo and you're crippled by intense. stomach discomfort. Yes, I suppose. Anyway, a bloke comes up to him with the message, the demand that he go back to Lisbon.
老实说，我认为巴西此时更像狂野西部。好吧。比你想象的要多。我认为当你身处丛林时，很难穿金编织和肩章。是的，你在圣保罗的荒地里，而且被严重的胃部不适所折磨。是的，我想。总之，一个家伙带着信息走到他面前，要求他回到里斯本。
Pedro reads the message and he throws it on the ground and he stamps on it. And his confessor is with him. And Pedro says to his confessor, what should I do? And the priest says, If your majesty does not make himself king of Brazil, he will be taken prisoner by the Kordesh and will probably be disinherited. There is no other path except for independence and separation. That's punchy stuff from the priest.
佩德罗读了信息，把它扔在地上，踩在上面。他的忏悔神父和他在一起。佩德罗对他的神父说，我该怎么办？神父说，如果陛下不让自己成为巴西国王，他将被科尔特斯俘虏，并可能被剥夺继承权。除了独立和分离，没有别的路。神父的话很有力。
Yeah. And Pedro, to be fair to him, even though he's in a bad way. He responds excellently. He says, if this is what they want, this is what they'll get. The Cortesh are persecuting me. They refer to me with contempt as a wretched boy and a Brazilian. Well, they will
是的。佩德罗，对他公平地说，尽管他情况不好。他回应得非常好。他说，如果这就是他们想要的，这就是他们会得到的。科尔特斯在迫害我。他们轻蔑地称我为“可怜的男孩”和“巴西人”。好吧，他们会
see what this wretched boy can do. And then he tears from his hat the white and blue Portuguese ribbon. At this point, white and blue are the colors of the Portuguese monarchy. And he draws his sword and he shouts unimprovably. The time has come.
看看这个可怜的男孩能做什么。然后他从帽子上扯下了白色和蓝色的葡萄牙丝带。此时，白色和蓝色是葡萄牙君主制的颜色。他拔出剑，大喊道，不可磨灭地。时刻到了。
Independence or death. That is so South American, isn't it? It's very South American. And people may doubt this because they may say, surely this didn't happen. But actually, there are three separate eyewitness accounts that say that it did. Yeah. And it's exactly the kind of thing, a romantically inclined young prince in South America. It's exactly what he'd say.
独立或死亡。那太南美了，不是吗？非常南美。人们可能会怀疑这一点，因为他们可能会说，这肯定没有发生。但实际上，有三个独立的目击者记录说它确实发生了。是的。这正是那种浪漫倾向的年轻王子在南美洲会说的话。
Even if suffering horrendous stomach cramps. Yes. So he returns to Rio a few days later. And he's in very good spirit. So he's recovered from his dysentery. He's recovered. And he's already wearing. new colours. Instead of the blue and white of the Portuguese royal family, he's now wearing green
即使遭受可怕的胃痉挛。是的。所以几天后他回到了里约。他精神很好。所以他从痢疾中恢复了。他恢复了。而且他已经在穿了。
and yellow. And the reason he's wearing green and yellow, we'll talk about the flag a little bit in the second half when we talk more about anthems. The green comes from his father's Braganza dynasty. Green is their colour. And he is married to a Habsburg. So the yellow is the house of Austria. So the yellow in the Brazilian flag is Habsburg. Yeah. Wow. The green and yellow in the Brazilian flag are the colours of House of Bruganza and the House of Habsburg. You get the sense with Maximilian, the Habsburg Last Emperor of Mexico.
新颜色。他不再穿葡萄牙王室的蓝色和白色，现在他穿绿色和黄色。他穿绿色和黄色的原因，我们将在下半场谈论国歌时更多地谈论旗帜。绿色来自他父亲的布拉干萨王朝。绿色是他们的颜色。他娶了一位哈布斯堡家族的人。所以黄色是奥地利家族。所以巴西国旗中的黄色是哈布斯堡。是的。哇。巴西国旗中的绿色和黄色是布拉干萨家族和哈布斯堡家族的颜色。你从马克西米利安，哈布斯堡墨西哥末代皇帝身上能感觉到。
The Habsburgs are not at their best in the new world. No, not in their best in the new world, but clearly not. No, the whole of the new world should belong to the Habsburgs, I think, except for the northern bit which should be British, all be British. So on the 20th of September, the Rio newspapers published the news that he has declared independence. says, independence or death, this is the cry that unites all Brazilians. Brazil has awoken from her lethargy and has resolved with dignity to shake off the weight that has oppressed her. And two days
哈布斯堡家族在新世界表现不佳。不，在新世界表现不佳，但显然不是。不，整个新世界都应该属于哈布斯堡家族，我想，除了北部应该属于英国的部分，都应该属于英国。所以9月20日，里约的报纸发布了他宣布独立的消息。说，“独立或死亡，这是团结所有巴西人的呼声。巴西已经从昏睡中醒来，并决心以尊严摆脱压迫她的重担。”两天后，
later, he writes his father, the most famous letter in Brazilian history, a very overwrought letter. I, as the Prince Regents of the Kingdom of Brazil and its perpetual defender, declare null and void all the decrees and all else that has been imposed on Brazil by these factious, abhorrent, Machiavellian, chaotic, depraved and pernicious cortesh. He loves an adjective. That's the Portuguese Parliament. He does. They are no more than a gang of villainous anti-monicists and murderers who are holding
他写信给他父亲，这是巴西历史上最著名的信，一封非常夸张的信。我，作为巴西王国的摄政王及其永久捍卫者，宣布由这些派系、令人厌恶、马基雅维利式、混乱、堕落和有害的科尔特斯强加给巴西的所有法令及其他一切无效。他喜欢形容词。那是葡萄牙议会。他确实喜欢。他们不过是一群卑鄙的反君主主义者和杀人犯，他们正在将
your majesty in the most ignominious captivity. Brazilian independence triumphs and will triumph or we will die defending it. It's quite Prince Harry to Charles III. Prince Harry, yes. Gosh, if he could go to Canada or something in the Claire. I mean, Canada is independent, I suppose, but he could cast off the British monarchy and set himself up as a rival Canadian monarch, I suppose. I think you'd be quite suited to Canada.
陛下置于最可耻的囚禁中。巴西独立胜利了，并将继续胜利，否则我们将死于捍卫它。这很像哈里王子对查尔斯三世。哈里王子，是的。天哪，如果他能去加拿大之类的宣布。我的意思是，加拿大是独立的，我想，但他可以抛弃英国君主制，把自己建立成一个竞争的加拿大君主，我想。我想你很适合加拿大。
Vince Harry? Yeah. No. Yeah. The Canadians are quite hardy people. Harry's fought in Afghanistan. The Canadians wouldn't do all that business with Elizabeth Arden cream, surely, when they got frostbite. Of course, they would.
哈里王子？是的。不。是的。加拿大人是相当坚韧的人。哈里在阿富汗打过仗。加拿大人肯定不会在冻伤时做所有那些伊丽莎白·雅顿面霜的事情。当然，他们会。
No, they would. Canadians are both, they're kind of, you know, Mounties. They like kind of galloping around in the world. I'm just thinking about, suddenly I've just thought about Justin Trudeau, and I think you might be right. Yeah, exactly. But also, they're very, very kind of woke and stuff. They're very woke.
不，他们会。加拿大人既是，他们有点，你知道，骑警。他们喜欢在世界上驰骋。我只是在想，我突然想到了贾斯汀·特鲁多，我想你可能是对的。是的，没错。而且，他们非常，非常，你知道，觉醒之类的。他们非常觉醒。
Not all of them, though. The Prince Harry Ford in Afghanistan ticks one box and the woke stuff ticks another box. It feels to both. It goes to both Mark Carney and Puellyre for or something. A man who looks like a Tory MP from a casting agency. And all the truck drivers. Yes, the Alberta people.
不过不是所有人。哈里王子在阿富汗打仗勾选了一个框，觉醒的东西勾选了另一个框。它感觉两者都有。它去马克·卡尼和普瓦列夫尔或什么的。一个看起来像选角机构的保守党议员的人。还有所有的卡车司机。是的，阿尔伯塔人。
The Alberta drivers. Alberta oilmen. I don't think Alberta or Allman surely have any time. No, sorry, I'm getting the model. The Alberta Orleman and Mark Carney. Right. He took both. Anyway, listen to this is irrelevant.
阿尔伯塔司机。阿尔伯塔石油人。我不认为阿尔伯塔或石油人肯定有任何时间。不，抱歉，我搞错了模型。阿尔伯塔石油人和马克·卡尼。对。他两者都占了。总之，听着，这无关紧要。
Well, it's great to have some Canada on the show anyway. Well, they are hosting the World Cup. So Brazil has become independent, and Pedro becomes Don Pedro the first, constitutional emperor and perpetual defender of Brazil. And the green and gold, the new green and gold colors are flying everywhere. There's loads of merch. There's fans. There's mugs. There's clocks.
好吧，很高兴节目里有一些加拿大内容。好吧，他们正在主办世界杯。所以巴西已经独立，佩德罗成为佩德罗一世，巴西的宪政皇帝和永久捍卫者。绿色和金色，新的绿色和金色旗帜到处飘扬。有很多周边商品。有粉丝。有杯子。有钟表。
There's loads of stuff in these new colors. So it's a very unusual revolution. Schwartz and Starling in their books say it's both unique and banal, liberal and conservative. because on the one hand, they've created a new country. On the other hand, basically, there's absolutely no talk really of a republic or of a new dawn. It's not like the American Revolution or the French Revolution. It's a new imperial monarchy. And there's no talk of abolitionism.
这些新颜色里有很多东西。所以这是一场非常不寻常的革命。施瓦茨和斯塔林在他们的书中说它既独特又平庸，自由又保守。因为一方面，他们创造了一个新国家。另一方面，基本上，真的完全没有关于共和国或新黎明的讨论。它不像美国革命或法国革命。这是一个新的帝国君主制。而且没有关于废奴主义的讨论。
No hint of abolitionism, no talk of a challenge to slavery. In fact, the people who are leading this revolution are people who often own lots of slaves. They're land-owning elite. What the Brazilians want to do, they look at what's going on with the Spanish Empire, which has all completely fallen apart. and feuding and, you know, chaos. They want to avoid anything similar. And that's why they go for an empire.
没有废奴主义的暗示，没有对奴隶制提出挑战的讨论。事实上，领导这场革命的人是经常拥有大量奴隶的人。他们是土地所有精英。巴西人想做的是，他们看看西班牙帝国正在发生什么，它已经完全分崩离析了。而且争吵，你知道，混乱。他们想避免任何类似的事情。这就是为什么他们选择帝国。
They think an empire is the best way to keep this vast, sprawling territory of Brazil intact. And the emperor will function as a focal point. And the emperor will allow us to transcend the regional divisions. It's actually not a bad system. I think it's quite smart. So you've got an emperor? You've got a flag.
他们认为帝国是保持巴西这片广阔、蔓延的领土完整的最好方式。而皇帝将作为一个焦点。皇帝将允许我们超越区域分歧。这实际上不是一个坏系统。我认为它相当聪明。所以你有一个皇帝？你有一面旗帜。
Yeah. What about an anthem? Well, this is the thing. Who would you get to write the anthem of your new country. And the answer is you want somebody who's really invested in it. Somebody who's already shown himself
是的。国歌呢？嗯，这就是问题所在。你会找谁来写你新国家的国歌。答案是你想要一个真正投入其中的人。一个已经表现出自己
to care a lot about independence and a man who will defy physical discomfort to do his bit for his country. Does Don Pedro write it? Don Pedro himself writes the tune for the new anthem which is called the Hymn of Independence.
非常关心独立的人，一个会无视身体不适为国家尽自己一份力的人。佩德罗写了吗？佩德罗本人为新国歌写了曲子，这首歌被称为《独立赞歌》。
Now it's possible and indeed likely that he had help from court musicians but as far as I can tell there isn't a single Brazilian historian who seriously doubts that he wrote it. He did write it himself. So he's the most musical empress. It's Nero.
现在，他可能确实得到了宫廷音乐家的帮助，这很可能，但据我所知，没有一个巴西历史学家真正怀疑是他写的。他确实是自己写的。所以他是最有音乐天赋的皇帝。是尼禄。
Yeah. He didn't write the words, though. So the words were written by a poet and newspaper editor called Evaristo Ferreira da Vega and Barros. And it's incredibly long, this first anthem. How long is it? It's not as long as the Dutch. It's probably about eight verses or ten rather than 14. What's the standard of the lyrics?
是的。不过他没写歌词。所以歌词是由一位名叫埃瓦里斯托·费雷拉·达·维加·伊·巴罗斯的诗人和报纸编辑写的。这首第一首国歌非常长。有多长？它没有荷兰国歌那么长。它可能有八节或十节，而不是14节。歌词的标准如何？
Poor, I think really poor. I think actually Don Pedro comes out better than Everese. Fierreira de Vega Ibaros. Because some of the... I'll give you an example of the lyrics. The Auguste Royal Air, knowing the vile deceit in spite of the tyrants, wish to stay in his Brazil,
很差，我认为真的很差。我认为实际上佩德罗比埃瓦里斯托·费雷拉·达·维加·伊·巴罗斯表现得更好。因为一些……我会给你举个歌词的例子。“奥古斯特皇家空气，知道卑鄙的欺骗，尽管有暴君，希望留在他的巴西，
in spite of the tyrants, in spite of the tyrants, wish to stay in his Brazil. That's one verse. Pedro show your face, your bold and virile soul. We have in him the worthy chief of this empire of Brazil.
尽管有暴君，尽管有暴君，希望留在他的巴西。”这是一节。佩德罗展示你的脸，你大胆而阳刚的灵魂。我们有他作为这个巴西帝国的杰出首领。
We have in him the worthy chief, we have in him the worthy chief of this empire of Brazil. It's not a banger. It's not a banger, But you can see the appeal of it to Don Pedro, I guess, if there's going to be an anthem in which he's being praised for his bold and virile soul. Exactly, exactly. For the next nine years, this is the sound of Brazilian freedom.
我们有他作为这个杰出的首领，我们有他作为这个巴西帝国的杰出首领。”这不是一首热门歌曲。这不是一首热门歌曲，但你可以看出它对佩德罗的吸引力，我想，如果有一首国歌，他在其中因为他大胆而阳刚的灵魂而受到赞扬。没错，没错。在接下来的九年里，这就是巴西自由的声音。
But bad news for fans of Don Pedro, the first. Or is not well in his Brazil. Because I said at the beginning how violence and unstable it is. Throughout the 1920s, there are a series of revolts. And there's a massive revolt in the northern province of Pernambuco. And the rebels there call for a separate. Confederation of the Equator, which has to be put down by the army. I mean, this is so South American.
但对于佩德罗一世的粉丝来说，这可是个坏消息。他的巴西并不太平。因为我开头就说过，这里充满了暴力和动荡。整个19世纪20年代，起义不断。在北部的伯南布哥省发生了一场大规模起义。那里的叛军呼吁建立一个独立的“赤道联邦”，最终不得不由军队镇压。我的意思是，这太南美了。
There's then a big blow to his prestige in 1825. He and his army lose control of their southernmost province, which is the Spanish-speaking province of Cis Platina, and this becomes the independent country of Uruguay, set up with British protection, because the British fancied having a friendly port on the river plate. the first winner of the World Cup, of course. Exactly, first winning the Royal Cup.
随后，他的威望在1825年遭受了沉重打击。他和他的军队失去了对最南端省份的控制，也就是讲西班牙语的西斯普拉蒂纳省，这成为了独立的乌拉圭，是在英国的保护下建立的，因为英国人想在拉普拉塔河拥有一个友好的港口。当然，它是世界杯的第一个冠军。没错，第一个赢得皇家杯的冠军。
I'm actually a big fan of Uruguay. I like Uruguay. I know you are. And then a year later, 1826, there are two big developments in Don Pedro's private life. First of all, his father, Domzhouout the 6th, dies in his palace outside Lisbon back in Portugal. And it's not clear who's going to succeed him.
我其实是乌拉圭的忠实粉丝。我喜欢乌拉圭。我知道你喜欢。一年后，即1826年，佩德罗的私生活发生了两件大事。首先，他的父亲若昂六世在葡萄牙里斯本郊外的宫殿里去世了。目前还不清楚谁将继承他的王位。
Could Don Pedro succeed him and become king of both kingdoms? Become emperor and king again. Will somebody else in the family succeed him? Or Don Pedro's preferred solution, his own daughter. So who's called Maria? Will she succeed his father? I'm on the edge of my seat. Then in December 1826, the other development,
佩德罗能继承王位并成为两个王国的国王吗？再次成为皇帝和国王。家族里的其他人会继承吗？还是佩德罗首选的方案，他自己的女儿，那个叫玛丽亚的女孩？她会继承他父亲的王位吗？我真是拭目以待。然后在1826年12月，另一件事发生了，
his Habsburg wife, Maria Leopoldina, dies in childbirth. He has been a very poor husband. He's had loads of affairs. He's been a massive predator. And because of this, rumors sweep Rio that she has died because he has beaten her and being brutal and neglectful and so on. So that's bad for him. And by the end of the decade, the mood in Rio has definitively turned against him.
他的哈布斯堡妻子玛丽亚·利奥波丁娜在分娩时去世了。他一直是个很糟糕的丈夫。他有很多外遇。他是个十足的掠夺者。正因如此，里约热内卢流言四起，说她是因为被他殴打、遭受残酷对待和忽视而死的。这对他的名声很不利。到那个十年结束时，里约的民意已经彻底转向反对他了。
People say he's a selfish brute, his wife died and it was his fault. And all he cares about is getting the Portuguese throne for his daughter Maria, because now there's a kind of civil war going on in Portugal. So on the night of the 11th of March, 1831, riots break out in the city of Rio. And this is an event known, you will. know, Tom. It's called the Knight of Bottles. I mean, of course, I do know that, but I'll tell you what always why bottles? People are throwing bottles. Okay, of course. It's pretty straightforward, to be honest. Right. So the Knights of Bottles unusually lasts for five days. The nights of bottles
人们说他是个自私的野蛮人，他妻子的死是他的错。他唯一关心的就是为他的女儿玛丽亚争取葡萄牙王位，因为当时葡萄牙正处于某种内战之中。所以，在1831年3月11日晚上，里约城爆发了骚乱。汤姆，你应该知道这个事件。它被称为“瓶子之夜”。我的意思是，我当然知道，但我得问问，为什么是瓶子？人们在扔瓶子。好吧，当然。说实话，这很直白。对。所以“瓶子之夜”不同寻常地持续了五天。瓶子之夜
usually lasts just one day. I think a knight usually lasts a knight, no? You're right. Yeah. I think the clue is usually in the name, but not in this case. It's different in the southern hemisphere and in the new world. So magical realist. It is. So, so. there are all these crowds fighting, liberals are shouting, long live the Constitution, blah, blah, throwing bottles. The city's Portuguese community, because the city has a Portuguese community, they're shouting for Don Pedro. Weirdly, he was the bloke who abandoned Portugal, but they're very much now on his side. Don Pedro, his cabinet, say to him, okay, well, to shore up your regime, you need to crack down on the Portuguese expac community. They're absolute snakes that you've got
通常只持续一天。我想一个夜晚通常只持续一个夜晚，对吧？你说得对。是的。我想线索通常就在名字里，但这次不是。在南半球和新世界情况不同。真是魔幻现实主义。确实。所以，到处都是打斗的人群，自由派在喊“宪法万岁”之类的，扔着瓶子。城市的葡萄牙社区，因为城里有葡萄牙社区，他们在为佩德罗欢呼。奇怪的是，他明明是那个抛弃了葡萄牙的家伙，但他们现在非常支持他。佩德罗的内阁对他说，好吧，为了巩固你的政权，你需要打击葡萄牙侨民社区。他们绝对是毒蛇，你必须
to crack down on these people. Make an example of them. He says, no way. I mean, I'm a Portuguese expat myself. And he sacks all his ministers and appoints a lot of cronies, loads of riots, loads of protests. He tries everything to calm the crowds. But basically, it's like, remember we did the Iranian Revolution? I do. It's like that, but sort of jollier and jauntier. So there are, you know, regular demonstrations and riots and stuff.
打击这些人。杀鸡儆猴。他说，没门。我的意思是，我自己就是个葡萄牙侨民。于是他解雇了所有部长，任命了一堆亲信，引发了大量的骚乱和抗议。他尝试了一切办法来平息人群。但基本上，就像我们之前讲过的伊朗革命一样？我记得。就像那样，但稍微更欢乐、更轻快一些。所以，你知道，有定期的示威和骚乱之类的。
And eventually, he thinks, well, if I don't do something decisive, there's going to be a cause for a republic. That is the last thing we want. So in the early hours of the 7th of April, 1831, Don Pedro I, the first, the first emperor of Brazil, announces that he will abdicate in favour of his son, who is only five years old, and is of course also called Pedro and will become Dom Pedro the second. Yeah, a friend of the show. Beard meteorite guy. Yeah, but who's only a little boy at this point. So Don Pedro I says to one of his courtiers, here you have my act of abdication. I am returning to Europe and leaving a country that I loved very much.
最终，他想，如果我不采取果断行动，就会有人要求建立共和国。这是我们最不想看到的。因此，在1831年4月7日凌晨，巴西第一任皇帝佩德罗一世宣布退位，传位给年仅五岁的儿子，他当然也叫佩德罗，将成为佩德罗二世。是的，节目的老朋友。那个胡子陨石男。是的，但他当时只是个小男孩。所以佩德罗一世对他的一个朝臣说，这是我的退位诏书。我要回欧洲了，离开一个我非常热爱的国家，
and still love. Everything is over between me and Brazil forever. Sad. He gets on a British warship. There's always
并且至今仍热爱。我和巴西之间的一切永远结束了。真悲伤。他登上了一艘英国军舰。故事里总是有
British warships hanging around in the story. He gets on a British warship. He goes back to Portugal. He fights this civil war. He gets the throne for his daughter
英国军舰在附近徘徊。他登上一艘英国军舰。他回到了葡萄牙。他打赢了这场内战。他最终为他的女儿
in the end. And then precisely the point that he's just got the throne for his daughter, he drops dead of TB, age 35. That's quite convenient, isn't it, for his daughter?
赢得了王位。然后就在他刚为女儿赢得王位时，他因肺结核去世了，年仅35岁。这对他的女儿来说很方便，不是吗？
For his daughter. And that is the end of Don Pedro the first. But, this raises a huge question for Brazil and for this podcast. Yes. So the anthem, because the anthem was all about him. So what are they going to do now?
对他的女儿来说。这就是佩德罗一世的结局。但是，这为巴西和这个播客提出了一个巨大的问题。是的。那么国歌呢，因为国歌全是关于他的。那他们现在该怎么办？
Yes. What are they going to do now? Wow. Okay. Well, if you enjoy a national anthem themed cliffhanger, then I guess this is the cliffhanger to beat them all. Come back after the break to find out what the new anthem will be. This episode is brought to you by Lloyds.
是的。他们现在该怎么办？哇。好吧，如果你喜欢以国歌为主题的悬念，那么我想这就是最棒的悬念了。休息后回来看看新国歌会是什么。本集由劳埃德银行赞助播出。
Now, when you have ambitions, being able to see the bigger picture is just so important. And history definitely teaches us that. My favorite example, not necessarily a brilliant man, but the Spanish conquistador Hernan Cortez. He was a visionary, he was an adventurer, but he also grasped that the empire of the Aztecs was vulnerable, and he took his men in land,
现在，当你拥有雄心壮志时，能够看到大局是非常重要的。历史绝对教会了我们这一点。我最喜欢的例子，虽然不一定是个伟大的男人，但西班牙征服者埃尔南·科尔特斯。他是个有远见的人，是个冒险家，但他同时也抓住了阿兹特克帝国脆弱的弱点，他带着他的人深入内陆，
and he was able to bring down the Aztecs with just a handful of men. And of course, this isn't just a problem for blood-soaked conquistadors. it is true for the rest of us as well, which is where Lloyd's comes in. Their app helps you to see all your finances in one place so that you can feel clearer and more confident about what comes next. And rather like Cortez, you're managing the micro and the macro. So one moment, you might be managing day-to-day spending with budgeting insights using the app, or you might be getting guidance if you're thinking about starting a business. So whatever your next move looks like, you can bank on Lloyd's to help you make it with confidence.
他仅凭少数人就推翻了阿兹特克人。当然，这不仅仅是血腥的征服者面临的问题，对我们其他人来说也是如此，这就是劳埃德银行的用武之地。他们的应用程序可以帮助你在一处查看所有财务状况，让你对未来感到更清晰、更自信。就像科尔特斯一样，你既要管理微观也要管理宏观。所以，你可能正在使用应用程序的预算洞察来管理日常支出，或者如果你正在考虑创业，你可能会获得指导。所以无论你的下一步是什么，你都可以信赖劳埃德银行，帮助你自信地迈出这一步。
Visit Lloydsbank.com. Hello everyone and welcome back to our Brazilian-themed Rest is History today and the year is 1831 and you join us in a Brazil that is in the midst of political turmoil but also musical turmoil because they have kicked out top-toonsta Pedro the first So what are they now going to do about this anthem that he's left them, which is basically him of praised his virility and strength and wisdom and stuff? They can't use it. Because he's proved himself to be useless, hasn't he?
访问 Lloydsbank.com。大家好，欢迎回到我们以巴西为主题的《历史的余味》。今天是1831年，你们加入我们时，巴西正处于政治动荡之中，但也处于音乐动荡之中，因为他们赶走了佩德罗一世。那么他们现在要怎么处理他留下的这首国歌呢？那首歌基本上是在赞美他的阳刚之气、力量和智慧之类的？他们不能再用了。因为他已经证明自己是个废物了，不是吗？
And the thing is, they can't use new words for the anthem because he wrote the tune. And it would be insane to have a tune written by the bloke you've just kicked out. Well, unless it's really good. Well, it's not that good, I don't think. It's not that good. I think it's just generic early 19th century sort of jolly music. But there's good news. A local composer is.
问题是，他们不能给国歌换新词，因为曲子是他写的。用一个刚被你们赶走的人写的曲子，那简直是疯了。除非它真的很好听。嗯，我不觉得它有多好听。它没那么好。我觉得它只是19世纪早期那种平庸的欢乐音乐。但有个好消息。一位当地作曲家
is already on the case. This is one of my favorite Brazilian composers of the 1820s, Francisco Manuel de Silva. Now, Francisco Manuel de Silva actually knew Don Pedro the first because he had played in the chapel orchestra at the Imperial Palace. But clearly he wasn't a fan of the emperor, because as soon as the news of the abdication broke, Silver had started writing a celebratory hymn.
已经在处理这件事了。这是我最喜欢的19世纪20年代巴西作曲家之一，弗朗西斯科·曼努埃尔·达·席尔瓦。弗朗西斯科·曼努埃尔·达·席尔瓦其实认识佩德罗一世，因为他曾在皇宫的教堂管弦乐队演奏过。但显然他不是皇帝的粉丝，因为退位消息一传出，席尔瓦就开始创作一首庆祝赞美诗。
And it took him six weeks to do it. He premiered it at the Sao Pedro Theatre, St. Peter Theatre. and then he performed it again at a special gala along with a drama entitled The Fall of the Tyrant. Okay, that's ungrateful. Very ungrateful. Anyway, he probably never envisaged this as a national anthem. The title is not really very snappy. The title is, to the great and heroic day of the 7th of April 1831, a hymn offered to the Brazilian people by a fellow countryman.
他花了六周时间才完成。他在圣佩德罗剧院首演了它，然后又在一个特别晚会上表演了它，同时还上演了一部名为《暴君的陨落》的戏剧。好吧，那太忘恩负义了。非常忘恩负义。总之，他可能从未想过这会成为国歌。这个标题一点也不响亮。标题是《献给1831年4月7日伟大而英勇的日子，一位同胞献给巴西人民的赞美诗》。
I mean, the problem with that is it's going to date fast, isn't it? It is going to date fast, yeah, because who's going to care about it? It's not clear at this point whether it has any lyrics or whether it's just instrumental. The lyrics aren't published publicly until two years later, so we don't know really whether they were sung at the first performance or whether they're actually written in the next two years. They were written by a liberal judge who was called Ovidio Sariva de Carvalio and Silva. And the general consensus among historians is that Ovidio Sariva's lyrics for this anthem are absolutely terrible. Oh, why? They're just babble.
我的意思是，那个标题的问题在于它很快就会过时，不是吗？确实会很快过时，因为谁会在乎呢？目前还不清楚它是否有歌词，还是纯器乐。歌词直到两年后才公开发表，所以我们真的不知道它们是在第一次演出时唱的，还是在接下来的两年里写的。它们是由一位名叫奥维迪奥·萨里瓦·德·卡瓦略·伊·席尔瓦的自由派法官写的。历史学家们的普遍共识是，奥维迪奥·萨里瓦为这首国歌写的歌词简直烂透了。哦，为什么？它们简直是胡言乱语。
They're really overwrought, and the only thing that distinguishes them is their ferocious hostility to the Portuguese. Which is not something you often get in song limits. I don't know many lucophobic songs. So to give you a sample of these lyrics, the canons of tyranny no longer roar in Brazil, the monsters that enslaved it no longer thrive among us. Barbarians of Jewish and Moorish blood be gone. Our homeland is no longer your treasure house. It's hard to imagine in the 21st century, people singing the lyrics,
它们写得非常夸张，唯一能让它们与众不同的就是对葡萄牙人的强烈敌意。这在国歌中并不常见。我不知道有多少仇视葡萄牙的歌曲。给你们举个例子：暴政的炮火在巴西不再轰鸣，奴役它的怪物不再在我们中间滋生。犹太和摩尔血统的野蛮人滚开。我们的家园不再是你们的宝库。很难想象在21世纪，人们会唱这样的歌词，
Barbarians of Jewish and Moorish blood. This is obviously a reference to the sort of, I guess, the Reconquista and Portugal's kind of history of religious diversity. Spain famously expelled both the Moors and the Jews. So maybe it's a reference to the fact that Portugal was distinct from that. Maybe. Maybe. Anyway, even at the time in the 1830s, a lot of people say, God, these are poor lyrics.
“犹太和摩尔血统的野蛮人”。这显然是指，我想，收复失地运动和葡萄牙那种宗教多样性的历史。西班牙著名地驱逐了摩尔人和犹太人。所以也许这是指葡萄牙与众不同。也许吧。也许。总之，即使在1830年代，很多人也说，天哪，这些歌词太差了。
And they drop them quite quickly. But they like the tune, Silver's tune. They would play it at public ceremonies without any words. So the years go by under Don Pedro II, the Second Emperor. Brazil is very chaotic. There is massive tension between Rio and the provinces. There are endless revolts and rebellions. There's another one on Pernambuco.
他们很快就弃用了它们。但他们喜欢这个曲子，席尔瓦的曲子。他们在公共仪式上演奏它，没有任何歌词。所以佩德罗二世，即第二任皇帝统治下的岁月流逝了。巴西非常混乱。里约和各省之间存在巨大的紧张关系。有无休止的起义和叛乱。伯南布哥又发生了一次。
There's a slave revolt in Bayer in 1835. there's an unbelievably bloody rebellion in the northern state of Parra in the late 1830s in which a third of the population were killed, about 30,000 people. And amazing, you never heard of it. No, exactly. So in 1841, the political elite decided that the only way to try to impose a bit of stability and get a bit of legitimacy for the central government was to bring forward the coronation of the 14-year-old boy emperor, friend of the show, Don Pedro the second.
1835年在巴伊亚发生了奴隶起义。19世纪30年代末，北部帕拉州发生了一场令人难以置信的血腥叛乱，三分之一的人口被杀，约3万人。令人惊讶的是，你从未听说过。不，确实。所以1841年，政治精英们决定，试图强加一点稳定并为中央政府获得一点合法性的唯一方法，就是提前为14岁的少年皇帝，也就是节目的老朋友佩德罗二世举行加冕礼。
Because why? I think they just think we want to show, you know, that... The state is functioning. Yeah, the state is functioning. A bit of braid. People love a bit of braid. Yeah. By this point, this anthem by Francisco Manuel de Silva, the one that he had written when
因为为什么？我想他们只是觉得我们想展示，你知道，……国家在运转。是的，国家在运转。一点装饰。人们喜欢一点装饰。是的。到这个时候，弗朗西斯科·曼努埃尔·达·席尔瓦创作的这首国歌，就是他在
Don Pedro was kicked out, this is accepted as the sort of de facto national anthem. So they commission new lyrics for it. The new lyrics are just as bad as the previous lyrics. I know. Why? Are they being horrible about the Portuguese again? No, they're not. They're just bland and they're just rubbishy.
佩德罗被赶走时写的那首，已经被接受为事实上的国歌了。所以他们为它委托了新的歌词。新歌词和之前的歌词一样糟糕。我知道。为什么？他们又在说葡萄牙人的坏话了吗？不，没有。它们只是平淡无奇，简直是垃圾。
Here we go. When you come, auspicious day, may happiness dawn among us. We see in Pedro II the adventure of Brazil. That's mad. That's going to date even faster. I mean, what happens if he dies? Well, they decide he's rubbish and drive him into his sight. Exactly.
开始了。当你到来，吉祥的日子，愿幸福在我们中间破晓。我们在佩德罗二世身上看到了巴西的冒险。那太疯狂了。那会过时得更快。我的意思是，如果他死了怎么办？好吧，他们决定他是个垃圾，把他赶走。没错。
At this point, the authorities basically say, okay, forget. Just keep humming. Yeah, just keep humming. So keep playing this hymn by Francisco Manuel de Silva. Whenever the monarch goes to public events, whenever this military ceremony is, but no lyrics. So for the next 40 years, Brazil has a tune, but it doesn't have any words. And Dominic, can I just ask, this tune is the tune that they still have to this day, is it?
此时，当局基本上说，好吧，算了。继续哼唱吧。是的，继续哼唱。所以继续演奏弗朗西斯科·曼努埃尔·达·席尔瓦的这首赞美诗。每当君主参加公共活动，每当有军事仪式时，但没有歌词。所以接下来的40年里，巴西有一首曲子，但没有歌词。多米尼克，我能问一下，这首曲子就是他们至今仍在使用的那首吗？
Yes, it is. When you see Brazil, the Brazilian team line up, the music that you hear is the one that they're all humming at this point. And remember, think about the lyrics they could have had. That's the question. They brought back a medley of the old lyrics. Anyway, so for the next 40 years, they have a tune but no words. You know, these are very turbulent and interesting 40 years for Brazil. This is the 40 years when they basically invent Brazilian identity.
是的，就是它。当你看到巴西队排队时，你听到的音乐就是他们现在都在哼唱的那首。记住，想想他们本可以有的歌词。这就是问题所在。他们带回了一段旧歌词的串烧。总之，接下来的40年里，他们有曲子但没有歌词。你知道，这对巴西来说是非常动荡和有趣的40年。这40年里，他们基本上发明了巴西人的身份。
So they have this idea of a unique tropical culture distinct from Europe, distinct from Portugal. Brazil actually manages to win a war. One of the bloodiest wars that people have never heard of, the War of the Triple Alliance against Paraguay. There was a guy called Lawrence Blair who came on last year to do a bonus episode about this. It's a mad war. So you listen to that. About a million people died in this war. insane. There are constant slave revolts. They do end up abolishing slavery in 1888. But presumably it remains
所以他们有了这种独特的、不同于欧洲、不同于葡萄牙的热带文化理念。巴西实际上成功赢得了一场战争。这是人们从未听说过的最血腥的战争之一，即反对巴拉圭的三国同盟战争。去年有个叫劳伦斯·布莱尔的人来做了一期关于这个的特别节目。这是一场疯狂的战争。所以你们去听听那个。大约有一百万人死于这场战争。太疯狂了。不断有奴隶起义。他们最终在1888年废除了奴隶制。但大概它仍然
kind of deeply racist. Massively embedded, even to the stay. Even to the stay, it's hugely embedded. Now, during all this time, Don Pedro II, as we described in our previous World Cup episode on Brazil in 2022, has been a pretty good emperor. He's very widely admired and respected abroad. He loves art. He loves science. He founds opera houses and things. He's quite a nice guy, isn't he? He's called the Louis the 14th of the tropics. But that's not necessarily... A good thing.
保持着根深蒂固的种族主义。大规模地根深蒂固，甚至直到今天。甚至直到今天，它依然根深蒂固。现在，在这段时间里，正如我们在之前关于2022年巴西世界杯的剧集中所描述的那样，佩德罗二世一直是一位相当不错的皇帝。他在国外受到广泛的钦佩和尊重。他热爱艺术。他热爱科学。他创办了歌剧院之类的。他是个相当不错的人，不是吗？他被称为“热带的路易十四”。但这不一定……是件好事。
A compliment. Yeah. I mean, Louis XIV isn't a very nice man. No, he's a much nicer guy than Louis XIV. He's a nice guy. He goes around writing letters, fan letters to like Richard Wagner and Louis Paster and Victor Hugo and stuff. The one thing he doesn't have is words for his anthem.
是种恭维。是的。我的意思是，路易十四并不是个很好的人。不，他比路易十四好得多。他是个好人。他到处写信，给理查德·瓦格纳、路易·巴斯德和维克多·雨果等人写粉丝信。他唯一没有的就是国歌的歌词。
He doesn't have that. There is one attempt during his reign to do something with the anthem, and this is courtesy of a very unexpected character. an American composer called Louis Moreau Gottschalk. And Gottschalk, he came from New Orleans. His father was a Jewish emigrant from London, and his mother was a Creole from the future Dominican Republic, Santa Domingo. And Gottschalk was a child prodigy who used to play the piano in hotels in New Orleans.
他没有那个。在他统治期间，曾有一次尝试处理国歌，这要归功于一个非常出人意料的人物。一位名叫路易·莫罗·戈特沙尔克的美国作曲家。戈特沙尔克来自新奥尔良。他的父亲是来自伦敦的犹太移民，他的母亲是来自未来的多米尼加共和国圣多明各的克里奥尔人。戈特沙尔克是个神童，过去常在新奥尔良的酒店里弹钢琴。
He was so talented that when he was 13, his father took him to Paris. And the Paris Conservatoire refused. to even hear him play when they found out he was American. The head of the piano faculty at the Paris Conservatoire said, and I quote, there is no point, America is a country of steam engines. So they didn't even hear him play. Anyway, what happened to Gottschalk? He traveled the Americas giving piano recitals.
他非常有天赋，13岁时，他父亲带他去了巴黎。巴黎音乐学院甚至拒绝听他演奏，因为他们发现他是美国人。巴黎音乐学院钢琴系主任说，我引用一下，“没必要，美国是个蒸汽机国家。”所以他们甚至没听他演奏。总之，戈特沙尔克后来怎么样了？他游历美洲，举办钢琴独奏会。
He was thrown out of the United States in 1865 after having been accused of having an affair with a piano student in Oakland, California. claimed that he had been framed by a rival of the piano manufacturer Chickering and Sons, which was the brand of piano that he used in his tours. And what's the thought on that? I didn't. I mean, who can say? I don't know.
1865年，他在加利福尼亚州奥克兰被指控与一名钢琴学生有染后，被赶出了美国。他声称自己是被钢琴制造商奇克林父子公司的竞争对手陷害的，那是他在巡演中使用的钢琴品牌。对此你怎么看？我不知道。我的意思是，谁能说得准呢？我不知道。
I don't even know what the rival was called. The references to this story is so opaque. I don't know who Chickering and Sons' great rivals were. I don't know how deeply they were embedded in the social life of Oakland, California. I have to just on this subject Skate over. Ignorance. Yeah.
我甚至不知道那个竞争对手叫什么。关于这个故事的参考资料太模糊了。我不知道奇克林父子公司的伟大竞争对手是谁。我不知道他们对加利福尼亚州奥克兰的社会生活有多深的影响。关于这个话题，我只能一笔带过。无知。是的。
Total ignorance. In the summer of 1869, Gottschalk arrived in Rio and he was greeted as a celebrity. Piano prodigies didn't often come to Rio. And Don Pedro II thought he was brilliant and was all over him. And Gottschalk decided to write two different works inspired by the Brazilian anthem. So he wrote a march that was dedicated to Pedro the second and a piano work called the Grand Triumphal Fantasy on the British.
完全无知。1869年夏天，戈特沙尔克抵达里约，受到名流般的欢迎。钢琴神童并不常来里约。佩德罗二世认为他很出色，对他非常器重。戈特沙尔克决定创作两部受巴西国歌启发的作品。他写了一首献给佩德罗二世的进行曲，以及一部名为《英国-巴西国歌大凯旋幻想曲》的钢琴作品，献给了佩德罗的女儿伊莎贝尔。
Brazilian national anthem, which was dedicated to Pedro's daughter, Isabel. And the grand triumphal fantasy was a massive hit at the time and remains current in Brazil to this day. There was a big sort of hoo-hah in the late 20th century about reinterpretations of the national anthem because the military dictatorship of the 60s and 70s tried to stamp them out. And the grand triumphal fantasies, bizarre as it sounds, came very popular on the left of Brazilian in politics and was used by the Democratic Labor Party in its TV ads in the 1980s. So this guy Got Schalk, the guy who'd possibly disgraced himself in Oakland or been framed by a
《大凯旋幻想曲》在当时非常受欢迎，至今在巴西仍很流行。20世纪末，关于国歌的重新诠释曾引起轩然大波，因为60和70年代的军事独裁政权试图压制它们。《大凯旋幻想曲》，听起来很奇怪，但在巴西左翼政治中变得非常流行，并在20世纪80年代被民主工党用于其电视广告中。所以这个家伙戈特沙尔克，那个可能在奥克兰丢了脸或者被钢琴制造商陷害的家伙。
piano manufacturer. I like to think the second. I like the sound of him. Anyway, so that's what happened to his Grand Trample Fantasy. You can look it up on YouTube and listen to it if that's the way you like to spend your time. Got Schalk himself came to a very sad end after he'd finished it. On the 24th of February 1869, he was playing the piano at a constant. concert in a Teatro lyrico fluminense in Rio.
我倾向于认为是后者。我喜欢他的声音。总之，这就是他的《大凯旋幻想曲》的结局。如果你喜欢把时间花在这些事情上，你可以在YouTube上搜索并听听它。戈特沙尔克本人在完成它后结局非常悲惨。1869年2月24日，他在里约的弗鲁米嫩塞抒情剧院举行音乐会。
He had just finished his own piece, which was unbelievably called Morty, death, when he collapsed. I can't believe you're laughing about this. Chortling away. It turned out he had yellow fever. Oh, that's even funnier. And a month later, he died in his hotel. But here's the weird thing.
他刚刚演奏完他自己的作品，那首作品的名字竟然叫《死亡》，然后他就倒下了。我不敢相信你竟然在笑。笑得这么开心。结果他得了黄热病。哦，那更搞笑了。一个月后，他在酒店去世了。但奇怪的是，
He didn't die of the yellow fever. He died of an overdose of quinine, which he'd presumably taken to combat the yellow fever. So that's a strange story. Anyway, back to Pedro the second. If you heard our previous podcast about him, you will recall that in the late 1880s, public opinion turned against him. They accused him of being a banana, didn't they? Do you remember that? Yeah. They used to call him Pedro Banana. And the other guy, who was the pair? Yeah, Louis-Philippe, some sort of great fruit salad bug. The whole series writes itself. It does. Okay. So people turn against him why the rich coffee planters were furious about the abolition of slavery. Liberal intellectuals had swung towards
他不是死于黄热病。他死于奎宁过量，他大概是为了对抗黄热病而服用的。所以这是一个奇怪的故事。总之，回到佩德罗二世。如果你听过我们之前关于他的播客，你会记得在19世纪80年代末，公众舆论转向反对他。他们指责他是个“香蕉”，不是吗？你还记得吗？是的。他们过去叫他“香蕉佩德罗”。还有另一个人，是谁？是的，路易-菲利普，某种水果沙拉虫。整个系列简直是自编自导。确实。所以人们转向反对他，为什么？富有的咖啡种植园主对废除奴隶制感到愤怒。自由派知识分子转向了
republicanism. They thought that he was old and boring and, you know, an unsuitable figurehead for Brazil. And the army had turned against him. They were obsessed with ideas about progress and modernisation. And they thought he and his court were backward and all this. So they basically kicked him out in November 1888 and they replaced him with this. Another old man, actually, a marshal with a massive beard called Marshal deodora de Fonseca. Well, what's the point in kicking out an old bloke because he's got a big beard
共和主义。他们认为他老了、无聊，你知道，是一个不适合巴西的傀儡。军队也转向反对他。他们沉迷于进步和现代化的思想。他们认为他和他的宫廷很落后等等。所以他们在1888年11月基本上把他赶走了，并用这个取代了他。另一个老人，实际上是一个留着大胡子的元帅，叫德奥多罗·达·丰塞卡元帅。好吧，因为一个老家伙留着大胡子就把他赶走，
and then introducing another one. Mad, insane, exactly. Especially as Don Pedro II was basically the best leader of Brazil's ever had. Yeah. Don Pedro the second didn't have the will to fight. He went off into Paris. He died in Paris and you may remember
然后又引进另一个，有什么意义？疯狂，荒谬，确实。尤其是佩德罗二世基本上是巴西有史以来最好的领导人。是的。佩德罗二世没有战斗的意志。他去了巴黎。他在巴黎去世了，你可能记得
he had a massive state funeral with basically hundreds of thousands of people turned out. Yeah, because they all loved him. Exactly. So Brazil is now a republic, dominated by the big coffee oligarchs and the army. Big coffee. Big coffee is genuinely running Brazil at this point.
他举行了盛大的国葬，基本上有成千上万的人参加。是的，因为他们都爱他。确实。所以巴西现在是一个共和国，由大咖啡寡头和军队统治。大咖啡。大咖啡在此时真正统治着巴西。
They rip Don Pedro's name of all the streets and all the buildings. It's the classic story. They changed the image on the banknotes. So like Philip II in the Dutch Revolt. Exactly. In a Dutch National Anthem podcast. They also tweak the flag. They do all sorts of things.
他们把佩德罗的名字从所有的街道和建筑物上抹去。这是经典的故事。他们改变了钞票上的图像。就像荷兰起义中的菲利普二世一样。确实。在荷兰国歌播客里。他们还调整了国旗。他们做了各种各样的事情。
But they keep the Habsburg stuff. Well, as we should see, they do. There's still the yellow, right? What colors are Brazil playing? They wear yellow shirts. They do need a new anthem. Well, they need new lyrics, right? Because the tune remains.
但他们保留了哈布斯堡的东西。好吧，正如我们将看到的，他们确实保留了。还有黄色，对吧？巴西穿什么颜色的球衣？他们穿黄色球衣。他们确实需要一首新国歌。好吧，他们需要新歌词，对吧？因为曲子保留了下来。
Well, they decide at this point they'd like a new tune as well. Okay. So they have a public contest for a new anthem. They have chosen the words already. They want the anthem to fit the words. They've chosen a poem by a liberal writer. And they've all got massive names. This writer is called Jose Joachim de Campos,
好吧，他们此时决定他们也想要一首新曲子。所以他们为新国歌举行了一场公开竞赛。他们已经选好了歌词。他们希望国歌符合这些歌词。他们选了一首自由派作家的诗。他们都有响亮的名字。这位作家叫若泽·若阿金·德·坎波斯，
the Kastor de Maudiro and Elbeke. And he's written the power. him? Please tell me this is good. It's not great actually. I mean, you tell me, I think it's probably better than the previous ones. I'll read it to you and you can tell me what you think. May this rebel song be an unfurled mantle of light under the vastness of these skies. This rebel song that comes to redeem our past from inglorious deeds. Liberty, liberty, above us spread thy wings through the struggles in the storm grant that we hear thy voice. It's better than the previous ones. It's better than the previous ones. A little gassy.
达·科斯塔·德·马迪罗·埃尔贝克。他写了这首诗。请告诉我这很好。其实不怎么样。我的意思是，你告诉我，我觉得它可能比之前的要好。我读给你听，你告诉我你怎么想。愿这首反叛之歌成为在这片广阔天空下展开的光明斗篷。这首反叛之歌是为了救赎我们过去那些不光彩的行为。自由，自由，在我们之上展开你的翅膀，在风暴的挣扎中，让我们听到你的声音。它比之前的要好。它比之前的要好。有点空洞。
Yeah, gassy. Exactly. Exactly. So these are the lyrics. 29 people enter the competition to write the tune. They have multiple rounds to the Eurovision Song Contestal. There is an ominous sign. Before the second round, a journalist asks this new president, Marshall Deidore, with his massive beard. What do you think of the entrance so far?
是的，空洞。确实。确实。所以这就是歌词。29个人参加了创作曲子的比赛。他们有多轮比赛，就像欧洲歌唱大赛一样。有一个不祥的迹象。在第二轮之前，一位记者问这位新总统，留着大胡子的德奥多罗元帅。你觉得目前的参赛作品怎么样？
Deidore said, I prefer the old anthem. Oh, okay. So they have the final at the Teatro Lyrico Fluminense, the place where Gottschalk, the pianist, with his yellow fever. They have the final at this theatre. They pay the finalists. They pay them all twice.
德奥多罗说，我更喜欢旧国歌。哦，好吧。所以他们在弗鲁米嫩塞抒情剧院举行了决赛，就是那个戈特沙尔克，那个得了黄热病的钢琴家表演的地方。他们在那个剧院举行了决赛。他们付钱给决赛选手。他们付了两次钱。
Marshall Deodoro and his ministers are listening in the Royal Box. Deidoro leaves the Royal Box to consult. It's like that moment in the Eurovision. When you're waiting for the results to come in, then he comes back into the box with his ministers. They retake their seats. The Interior Minister stands and he reads the result and he says, after all that, we'll stick with the old anthem after all.
德奥多罗元帅和他的部长们在皇家包厢里听着。德奥多罗离开包厢去商量。就像欧洲歌唱大赛中等待结果公布的那一刻。然后他和他的部长们回到包厢。他们重新坐下。内政部长站起来读出结果，他说，折腾了半天，我们最终还是保留旧国歌。
Good. They've stuck with the old anthem, but they haven't got any lyrics for it still. Marshall Deodoro falls from power after a year, falling out with Congress. Is this because they're crossed with him for not choosing a new album? No, I don't think the anthem plays a massive part in that, actually, frankly. It'd be nice claim and it would make the episode better. Yeah, but it wouldn't be true. The National Anthem revolt.
好。他们保留了旧国歌，但仍然没有歌词。德奥多罗元帅在一年后因与国会不和而下台。这是因为他们因为他没选新国歌而生他的气吗？不，我不认为国歌在其中起了很大作用，说实话。这会是个很好的说法，会让这一集更好看。是的，但那不是真的。国歌起义。
A Marshall Deodoros fall, just a year after they've kicked out of Don Pedro II, sets the tone for what follows. So to quote the Brazilian writer Pedro Vasquez, in the next century, Brazil had 12. 12 states of emergency, 19 military revolutions, two presidential resignations, three presidents prevented from assuming office, four presidents deposed, seven different constitutions, four dictatorships, and nine authoritarian governments, which is a lot. The consequence of that is that it's very difficult to arrive to consensus for new lyrics for the national... Precisely. Precisely. Not their priority. No. Basically, there'll be a coup in another year and they'll want their own lyrics.
德奥多罗元帅的倒台，就在他们赶走佩德罗二世一年后，为随后的事情定下了基调。所以引用巴西作家佩德罗·瓦斯克斯的话，在接下来的一个世纪里，巴西经历了12次紧急状态，19次军事革命，两次总统辞职，三位总统被阻止就职，四位总统被罢免，七部不同的宪法，四次独裁统治和九个威权政府，这非常多。其后果是，很难就国歌的新歌词达成共识……正是如此。正是如此。这不是他们的优先事项。不。基本上，明年又会发生政变，他们会想要自己的歌词。
So there's no lyrics. Now, the problem for the government, government is people have started to make up their own lyrics. There are complaints flooding in all the time. A, people will sing the anthem in school. Teachers will get their children, their pupils to sing the anthem, but the teachers will make up their own lyrics. And some regional governments have decided to start imposing their own lyrics, which are generally about their own state. So there'll be a supposedly national anthem, but it turns out that the lyrics are all like, oh, this state is absolutely brilliant and the best of all states and the others are useless or whatever.
所以没有歌词。现在，政府的问题是，人们已经开始自己编歌词了。投诉不断涌入。A，人们会在学校唱国歌。老师会让孩子们、学生们唱国歌，但老师会自己编歌词。一些地方政府决定开始强加他们自己的歌词，通常是关于他们自己的州。所以会有一首所谓的国歌，但结果歌词全是像“哦，这个州绝对是辉煌的，是所有州中最好的，其他的都是废物”之类的。
Well, unless you're Bertolt Brecht. Yes, I guess so. Yeah, we're no better than anybody else. Hopefully in the future people won't recoil from us in horror anymore. Yeah. In 1909, they held yet another contest to write lyrics for the old anthem. And this is won by a man called Osorio Duke Estrada. He is the man who wrote the lyrics that exist today.
好吧，除非你是贝托尔特·布莱希特。是的，我想是这样。是的，我们并不比任何人好。希望将来人们不会再惊恐地回避我们。是的。1909年，他们又举行了一次比赛，为旧国歌创作歌词。这次获胜的是一个叫奥索里奥·杜克·埃斯特拉达的人。他就是今天存在的歌词的作者。
What does he like? This man who sets his stamp on Brazilian world. musical history. It's hard to find out anything very interesting about him. He's a sort of generic early 20th century, Latin American intellectual with a sort of curled mustache and a very stiff collar. He shares all the sort of idealistic enthusiasms of the early 20th century, so progress, modernity and so on. By winning this competition, he has landed himself in a world of pain because for the next decade, his lyrics are constantly being debated in Congress and in the press, and he has to rewrite them nine times.
他是个什么样的人？这个在巴西音乐史上留下印记的人。很难找到关于他任何非常有趣的事情。他是一个典型的20世纪初拉丁美洲知识分子，留着卷曲的胡子，领子很硬。他分享了20世纪初那种理想主义的热情，比如进步、现代性等等。通过赢得这场比赛，他陷入了痛苦的深渊，因为在接下来的十年里，他的歌词不断在国会和媒体中被辩论，他不得不重写了九次。
So he must be heartily sick of having won this competition. And this drags on and on and on. But by the early 1920s, the centenary of Brazilian independence. Now, you will recall, Tom, the most important date in Brazilian history is the 7th of September 1822. Yeah. When Don Pedro the second declared independence, well, the centenary. in 1922 is fast approaching. And Rio is going to host a World Expo to celebrate.
所以他一定对赢得这场比赛感到非常厌烦。这件事拖了又拖。但到了1920年代初，巴西独立百年纪念。现在，汤姆，你记得，巴西历史上最重要的日期是1822年9月7日。是的。当佩德罗二世宣布独立时，好吧，1922年的百年纪念快到了。里约将举办世界博览会来庆祝。
They do. I have so many World Expos at this time, not there? They do. People love a World Expo. They've got 14 countries are coming. A very strange lineup, actually. So the people you'd expect to go, like the US, Britain, France are going, Portugal are going. Also just a little random European countries, Czechoslovakia, Denmark, Norway, but not many
他们确实举办了。我当时有那么多世界博览会，不是吗？他们确实举办了。人们喜欢世界博览会。有14个国家要来。阵容非常奇怪，实际上。所以你会期待去的人，比如美国、英国、法国都会去，葡萄牙也会去。还有一些随机的欧洲小国，捷克斯洛伐克、丹麦、挪威，但没有多少
South American countries. Is that because they're jealous? I think they just don't care. Yeah. Right. I don't know. Maybe they are jealous. They've built some absolutely thrilling attractions.
南美国家。是因为他们嫉妒吗？我想他们只是不在乎。是的。对。我不知道。也许他们是嫉妒。他们建造了一些绝对令人兴奋的景点。
So the main thing is a series of pavilions. There's the statistics pavilion. Oh, brilliant. There's the Agriculture and Roads Pavilion. There is the large industries pavilion. There is the small industries pavilion. I'm amazed more people aren't going. Well, Callum, very foolishly, I think, has said it sounds rather like the rest of history festival.
所以主要是一系列展馆。有统计展馆。哦，太棒了。有农业和道路展馆。有大型工业展馆。有小型工业展馆。我很惊讶没有更多人去。好吧，卡勒姆，我认为非常愚蠢地，说它听起来很像《历史的余味》节。
Hampton Corp Hallas. Yeah, people who come into that are going to love our statistics tend. But three million people go to this expo in Rio. So that's even more than are going to the rest of History Festival at Hampton Court Palace. The opening of the small industries and statistics pavilions is fast approaching. They need an anthem. They need the lyrics. So eventually the federal government do a deal with this bloke Osorio duke Estrada.
汉普顿宫大厅。是的，来这里的人会喜欢我们的统计展位。但有三百万人参加了里约的这次博览会。所以这比去汉普顿宫《历史的余味》节的人还要多。小型工业和统计展馆的开幕式快到了。他们需要一首国歌。他们需要歌词。所以最终联邦政府与这个叫奥索里奥·杜克·埃斯特拉达的家伙达成了协议。
They say, okay, we're just going to stop now. Stop changing the lyrics. we're going to buy them off you. They buy them off him for 5 million Rijs, which is apparently, I learn from some enthusiastic Googling, was half the price of a new car in Rio at the time. Oh, so not very much.
他们说，好吧，我们现在就停止。停止修改歌词。我们要买断你的版权。他们以500万雷亚尔买下了它们，我从一些热情的谷歌搜索中了解到，这在当时里约买一辆新车价格的一半。哦，所以没多少钱。
It's not enormous amount. No. I mean, you have to write another anthem. If you get what's the rest of the car. Yeah, to get the rest of the car. The very first radio broadcast in Brazilian history was the playing of this new anthem, well, it's the old anthem with the new lyrics.
这不是巨大的金额。不。我的意思是，你必须写另一首国歌。如果你得到剩下的车钱。是的，为了得到剩下的车钱。巴西历史上第一次广播是播放这首新国歌，好吧，它是带有新歌词的旧国歌。
On the morning of the 7th of September, it was broadcast from Corcovado, which is this mountain above Rio, the mountain where the Statue Christ the Redeemer stands today. And actually Christ the Redeemer, they began work on it this year, so the first foundations had been laid while the sound of the anthem is drifting across the city. So it's a great year for Brazilian identity, national identity. It is. It's a brilliant year for Brazilian identity.
在9月7日的早晨，它从科尔科瓦多山广播出来，那是里约上方的那座山，也就是今天基督救世主雕像矗立的山。实际上，基督救世主雕像，他们今年开始动工，所以当国歌的声音飘过城市时，第一批地基已经打好了。所以这对巴西的身份，国家身份来说是伟大的一年。确实。这对巴西身份来说是辉煌的一年。
Now, we come to the lyrics. I will read these and you can tell me whether you think they're better than previous lyrics. So these are the lyrics you have today. Oh, beloved, idolized homeland. Hail, hail, adored land. Amongst a thousand others art thou, Brazil. O beloved homeland of the sons of this ground,
现在，我们来看看歌词。我读这些，你告诉我你觉得它们是否比之前的歌词好。所以这些就是你们今天拥有的歌词。哦，亲爱的，偶像化的祖国。万岁，万岁，受崇拜的土地。在成千上万的其他土地中，你是巴西。哦，这片土地儿女亲爱的祖国，
thou art a kind mother, beloved homeland, Brazil. I mean, they're like every other anthem. They're not great, are they? No, so, I mean, there are loads and loads of national anthems like that. So if we haven't done a national anthem, it's basic because they're all like that. They're slow generic and so flowery and meaningless, I think. I just don't think they're great. However, if you look up the text, there are three specific references,
你是一位慈祥的母亲，亲爱的祖国，巴西。我的意思是，它们就像其他所有国歌一样。它们不怎么样，不是吗？不，所以，我的意思是，有成千上万首那样的国歌。所以如果我们没有做过国歌，那基本上是因为它们都那样。它们缓慢、平庸、华丽且毫无意义，我想。我只是觉得它们不怎么样。然而，如果你查阅文本，有三个具体的参考，
which it might be interesting to unpick just quickly. So that was actually the chorus that I read there. That was the chorus. The opening lines of the first verse are, The Placid Shores of the Iparanga heard, the resounding shout of a heroic people and the sun of liberty in shining beam shone in the homeland sky at that instant.
可能快速拆解一下会很有趣。所以刚才我读的是副歌。那是副歌。第一段的开头几行是，“伊皮兰加平静的岸边听到了，英勇人民响亮的呐喊，自由的太阳在光芒中，在那一刻照亮了祖国的天空。”
So the Iparanga is the stream outside Sao Paulo where Don Pedro with diarrhea got the message and he shouted liberty or death and drew his sword in 1822. So it's kind of nice that Don Pedro is still baking there. A little nod. Exactly, exactly. The next reference, Brazil, an intense dream, a vivid ray of love and hope to earth descendeth, if in thy beautiful, smiling and limpid sky,
所以伊皮兰加是圣保罗外的一条小溪，佩德罗在那里收到了消息，他喊道“自由或死亡”，并在1822年拔出了剑。所以佩德罗还在那里烘焙，这很好。一个小小的致意。正是，正是。下一个参考，“巴西，一个强烈的梦想，一道爱与希望的生动光芒降临大地，如果在你美丽、微笑和清澈的天空中，”
the image of the cross blazeseth. Now, you might think the cross, this is Christian cross. It's not really. It's the southern cross. The word in Portuguese is cruzero. And this is this constellation that's only visible in the southern hemisphere. It was first described by a Portuguese astronomer, Zhao Farras, who had gone on the first voyage to Brazil in 1500. He set have an astrolabe on the beach to work out where they were using the stars and stuff. And he wrote a letter to King Manuel of Portugal describing the Southern Cross and including a rough sketch of it, the first sketch ever done. So the Southern Cross became a great symbol of Brazil, as it is a symbol of Australia and New Zealand. The new coat of arms of Republican Brazil
十字架的形象闪耀着。现在，你可能会认为这个十字架是基督教的十字架。其实不然。它是南十字座。葡萄牙语单词是cruzero。这是只有在南半球才能看到的星座。它最早由葡萄牙天文学家若昂·法拉斯（Zhao Farras）描述，他曾于1500年参加了第一次前往巴西的航行。他在海滩上架设了星盘，利用星星等来确定他们的位置。他写了一封信给葡萄牙国王曼努埃尔，描述了南十字座，并附上了一张粗略的草图，这是有史以来的第一张草图。因此，南十字座成为了巴西的一个伟大象征，正如它是澳大利亚和新西兰的象征一样。巴西共和国的新国徽
when Don Pedro II was kicked out actually includes the Southern Cross. So the Southern Cross matters great. The Cruzeiro matters great deal to Brazil. They had four different currencies in the 20th century called Cruzeiros. And there is, fittingly, as we're a World Cup series, there is a football team called Cruzeiro, founded in 1921 in Belor-Azont. And this is a team that produced two of the players from the 1970 World Cup winning team, Tostow and Piazza, and Gersigno, who scored in every round of the 1970 World Cup. He played a for Cruzeiro later on and Ronaldo, the original Ronaldo, if you remember him, Tom, with his gapy teeth.
在唐·佩德罗二世被驱逐后，实际上也包含了南十字座。所以南十字座非常重要。Cruzeiro对巴西意义重大。他们在20世纪有四种不同的货币被称为Cruzeiros。而且，恰如其分的是，既然我们是在做世界杯系列节目，有一支名为Cruzeiro的足球队，于1921年在贝洛奥里藏特成立。这支球队培养了1970年世界杯冠军队的两名球员，托斯唐（Tostao）和皮亚扎（Piazza），还有在1970年世界杯每轮比赛中都有进球的雅伊尔津霍（Jairzinho）。他后来也为Cruzeiro效力，还有罗纳尔多，如果你还记得他的话，汤姆，那个有着大门牙的原始罗纳尔多。
Kind of bald. Yes, he played for Cruzeiro before he moved to PSV, I'd have. A little bit like Zach Polanski. Yeah, I can see the resemblance. Similar teeth. Yeah. Better at football than Zach Planozky. Yeah, much better.
有点秃顶。是的，他在转会到埃因霍温之前为Cruzeiro效力过，我想应该是。有点像扎克·波兰斯基（Zach Polanski）。是的，我能看出相似之处。牙齿很像。是的。足球踢得比扎克·波兰斯基好。是的，好多了。
Who doesn't strike me as a natural sportsman. He doesn't exude athletic prowess, does he? No. So near the end of the anthem, there's one of the, the reference, Brazil of eternal love, may the starry ensign which thou displayest be a symbol. And the starry end sign is the Brazilian flag. And actually, we've made a few references to the Brazilian flag. Brazil's flag is surely one of the most distinctive in the world. Yeah, for sure. And I hadn't realized it was a Habsburg Tribune flag.
他给我的印象不是一个天生的运动员。他没有散发出运动天赋，对吧？没有。所以在国歌快结束时，有一句提到，“巴西，永恒的爱，愿你展示的星条旗成为象征”。而星条旗就是巴西国旗。事实上，我们已经提到过几次巴西国旗了。巴西国旗肯定是世界上最具特色的国旗之一。是的，当然。我之前没意识到它是一面哈布斯堡王朝的旗帜。
Yeah. So basically, although it's changed multiple times, it is a tweaked version of the original flag adopted by Don Pedro in 1822. So if Brazil beat, the Netherlands, Philip the second will have the last laugh. As a Habsburg. Yeah. Yeah, he would. So the green, as I said, the House of Bruganza, which ruled Portugal since 1422, the yellow diamond, Habsburg, that's Don Pedro's wife, Maria Leopoldina.
是的。所以基本上，虽然它改变过多次，但它是唐·佩德罗在1822年采用的原始国旗的微调版本。所以如果巴西击败荷兰，菲利普二世作为哈布斯堡家族的人，将会笑到最后。是的。是的，他会。所以绿色，正如我所说，代表自1422年以来统治葡萄牙的布拉干萨王朝，黄色菱形代表哈布斯堡王朝，那是唐·佩德罗的妻子玛丽亚·利奥波丁娜的家族。
Then there's a blue circle in the middle. Now, originally in the blue circle, there was an astrolabe, hence the thing that you use to look at the stars. And the astrolabe is also in the middle of the port. Portuguese flag. But when they kicked out the Portuguese, they replaced it with the stars, including the Southern Cross, and their stars represent the 27 different states of Brazil. And finally, there is a motto. So Brazil's flag is very unusual having a motto written on it. And the motto is Ording and Progressal. And this means order and progress. And this is a quotation
中间有一个蓝色圆圈。最初，蓝色圆圈里有一个星盘，也就是你用来观察星星的那个东西。星盘也出现在葡萄牙国旗的中间。但当他们驱逐了葡萄牙人后，他们用星星取代了它，包括南十字座，这些星星代表巴西的27个不同州。最后，还有一个座右铭。所以巴西国旗非常独特，上面写着座右铭。座右铭是“秩序与进步”（Ordem e Progresso）。这是一句引语
from a French writer, Auguste Comte. L'amour per principle and l' order for as the progress for bubue love as a principle order as a basis progress as your goal order and progress it's the sort of motto the positivist movement and in latin america people were obsessed with positivism in the late 19th century so this is a sort of anti-clerical scientific progress strong central government embrace modernity all of this august count was the great sort of progenitor of this people loved him in Brazil and they put his order and progress on the flag. Unfortunately, order and progress were not really the guiding principles of Brazilian life in the 20th century.
来自法国作家奥古斯特·孔德（Auguste Comte）。“爱作为原则，秩序作为基础，进步作为目标”，秩序与进步，这是实证主义运动的座右铭。在19世纪末的拉丁美洲，人们对实证主义非常着迷。所以这是一种反教权、科学进步、强有力的中央政府、拥抱现代性的思想。奥古斯特·孔德是这一切的伟大鼻祖。巴西人很喜欢他，就把他的“秩序与进步”放在了国旗上。不幸的是，秩序与进步并不是20世纪巴西生活的真正指导原则。
And actually this Wednesday, Tom, we have a bonus episode with Paul Rouse, historian of sport as well as of Ireland, who is going to be talking about how the Brazilian military dictatorship, which ruled from 1964 to 1985, used football, and in particular the World Cup winning team of Pelle and Coe in 1970, how they used football to launder their image. So a very interesting story. Anyway, the anthem itself never has a fixed political meaning, and that's been true of so many anthems that we've talked about.
事实上，汤姆，这个星期三，我们有一期特别节目，嘉宾是体育史学家兼爱尔兰史学家保罗·劳斯（Paul Rouse），他将谈论1964年至1985年统治巴西的军事独裁政权是如何利用足球，特别是1970年贝利等人的世界杯冠军队，来洗白他们的形象。这是一个非常有趣的故事。总之，国歌本身从来没有固定的政治含义，我们谈论过的许多国歌都是如此。
So you know how we were talking before in previous episodes about how people would basically co-opt or appropriate anthems? Yeah. And to turn them for political purposes. Well, this has been the case with the Brazilian anthem too. So in the 1990s, when poor rural workers were demonstrating and occupying farms and calling for land reform, they would sing the national anthem. And one of them said later, when she was interviewed, she said it was the best way to stop the police from attacking us. They had no way of shooting at unarmed people who were singing the Brazilian national anthem.
你知道我们之前在之前的剧集中谈到人们如何基本上共同选择或挪用国歌吗？是的。并将其用于政治目的。好吧，巴西国歌也是如此。所以在20世纪90年代，当贫困的农村工人在示威、占领农场并呼吁土地改革时，他们会唱国歌。其中一位女性后来在接受采访时说，这是阻止警察攻击他们的最好方法。他们没法向唱着巴西国歌的非武装平民开枪。
But also, of course, very popular on the right. So when Jaya Bolsonaro, the, I have to say, very unlovely president of Brazil, sort of... Big chum of Trump's. Yeah, Trump adjacent to president of Brazil. When he lost his bid for re-election in 2022 and his supporters went berserk to the sort of maga-style uprising, and a lot of them were filmed seeing the national anthem while doing Nazi salutes. Oh dear. Which I think is not very admirable.
但当然，它在右翼也非常受欢迎。所以当贾伊尔·博索纳罗（Jair Bolsonaro），我必须说，这位非常不可爱的巴西总统，某种程度上……特朗普的好哥们。是的，与特朗普关系密切的巴西总统。当他在2022年竞选连任失败，他的支持者陷入疯狂，进行类似MAGA风格的起义时，许多人被拍到在行纳粹礼的同时唱国歌。天哪。我认为这并不值得称赞。
But the most celebrated use of the anthem comes from the 1980s. So I mentioned the military dictatorship. In the mid-1980s, the military dictatorship was losing its grip on Brazilian society. And it was under huge pressure from a movement called Diretas Jha, direct elections already, which was demanding free presidential elections. And they organized these huge rallies with hundreds of thousands of people. And the rallies had lots of kind of cultural and sporting figures associated with the most famously, Socrates, the captain of Brazil.
但国歌最著名的使用来自20世纪80年代。我提到了军事独裁。在80年代中期，军事独裁对巴西社会的控制力正在减弱。它受到了一场名为“Diretas Ja”（立即直接选举）运动的巨大压力，该运动要求进行自由的总统选举。他们组织了这些有数十万人参加的巨大集会。集会上有很多与此相关的文化和体育人物，最著名的是巴西队长苏格拉底（Socrates）。
in 1982, who paid for a team called Corinthians and Sao Paulo, and he got all of his teammates to wear political messages on their shirts. Is that the only mention we get of Socrates? That's the only mention of getting of Socrates. Yeah. Oh, I was hoping for a little bit more. I teased you with it, but I mean, we can talk about Socrates privately if you're desperate to. If you want an analysis of like how he worked with Adair, Falcao and Cerezo in the
1982年，他为科林蒂安队和圣保罗队效力，他让所有的队友都在球衣上印上政治信息。这是我们唯一一次提到苏格拉底吗？这是唯一一次提到苏格拉底。是的。哦，我本来希望能多一点。我用它逗了你一下，但我的意思是，如果你非常渴望的话，我们可以私下谈谈苏格拉底。如果你想要分析他是如何与阿德尔（Adair）、法尔考（Falcao）和塞雷佐（Cerezo）在
midfield of 1982, Tom. I am the person to talk you through that. And his relationship with Plato. Yeah, exactly. How does this relate to the anthem, this movement that Socrates is a part of? One of the most celebrated figures in this movement was a singer called Fafada Balang, who was then in her late 20s. And she was seen as a great sex symbol in the 1980s, the voice of the masses.
1982年的中场配合，汤姆。我是最适合跟你谈论这个的人。还有他与柏拉图的关系。是的，完全正确。这与国歌有什么关系，苏格拉底参与的这场运动？这场运动中最著名的形象之一是一位名叫法法·德·贝伦（Fafá de Belém）的歌手，她当时20多岁。在80年代，她被视为伟大的性感象征，大众的声音。
So she has this very low, husky voice, a little bit like the sound that you associate with Portuguese Fardo music. So this kind of husky kind of lament. Yeah. And she would go to these rallies for Fahdi's music. Adderbaling, and she would give this performance of the national anthem, the regime had banned anything but very, very formal interpretations of the anthem. They said you have to follow the 1920s orchestration. If you do anything else with it, you are disrespecting the anthem and disrespecting Brazil, so you can't do it in a different way. So this is a little bit like,
所以她有这种非常低沉、沙哑的声音，有点像你联想到的葡萄牙法朵（Fado）音乐的声音。所以这种沙哑的哀歌。是的。她会去参加这些法朵音乐的集会。阿德尔·巴林（Adderbaling），她会演唱国歌。政权禁止了除非常、非常正式的国歌演绎之外的任何东西。他们说你必须遵循1920年代的管弦乐编排。如果你用其他方式处理它，你就是在不尊重国歌，不尊重巴西，所以你不能用不同的方式演唱。所以这有点像，
remember the Starz Bang or Banner? And we were talking about Jimmy Hendricks and whatnot. Yeah. This carrying that to another degree. This is basically saying you're breaking the law if you do anything other than do it in this very rigid formal way. And she would go to these rallies with hundreds of thousands of people and she would give very, very dramatic reinterpretations of the anthem. But playing within the rules. No, breaking the rules. Breaking the rules. Incredibly slow, mournful, melodramatic and people would be crying during the anthem. Thousands of people would be crying while she was singing it. And it became the emblematic sound of protest in the 80s. And if people want a sense of what I mean, if you go onto her YouTube channel, you can find a
还记得《星条旗》吗？我们当时在谈论吉米·亨德里克斯（Jimmy Hendricks）之类的。是的。这将其提升到了另一个程度。这基本上是在说，如果你以除了这种非常僵化、正式的方式之外的任何方式演唱，你就是在违法。她会去参加有数十万人的集会，并对国歌进行非常、非常戏剧性的重新诠释。但这是在规则之内吗？不，打破规则。打破规则。极其缓慢、悲伤、夸张，人们在唱国歌时会哭泣。成千上万的人在她演唱时会哭泣。它成为了80年代抗议的标志性声音。如果人们想感受我的意思，如果你去她的YouTube频道，你可以找到一个
clip of her performing it in that style in the Senate in Brasilia in 2013. Because for the 25th anniversary of the new democratic constitution that had been introduced in 1988 when the dictatorship finally fell to celebrate the anniversary, they invited it. into the Senate to give her performance, to give her rendition, and she did it there to celebrate the fact that democracy had been reintroduced and the protesters had ultimately won. And so, Tom, we end with that very rare thing on the rest of history, a relatively happy ending. Well, that's wonderful. And actually, in the manner of speaking, we're going to have the same in our next episode, the final episode, which is going to be about the National Anthem of South Africa. And in that,
她在2013年巴西利亚参议院以那种风格演唱的片段。因为为了庆祝1988年独裁统治最终倒台后引入的新民主宪法25周年，为了庆祝周年纪念，他们邀请她进入参议院进行表演，进行她的演绎，她在那里演唱是为了庆祝民主制度的重新引入和抗议者最终的胜利。所以，汤姆，我们以“历史的其余部分”中非常罕见的事情结束，一个相对圆满的结局。嗯，那太棒了。事实上，顺便说一句，我们的下一集，也就是最后一集，也会有同样的情况，那一集将是关于南非国歌的。在那一集中，
as well as football, there will be quite a lot of rugby. Rugby, excellent. All right. So obviously, if you're a massive fan of rugby, or indeed if you're a fan of Nelson Mandela, you may want to listen to that immediately. And if you're not already a member of the Restist History Club, you can get that by joining us at the rest is history.com.
除了足球，还会有很多橄榄球。橄榄球，太棒了。好的。所以很明显，如果你是橄榄球的超级粉丝，或者如果你是纳尔逊·曼德拉的粉丝，你可能想立即收听那一集。如果你还不是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，你可以通过加入我们来获得，网址是therestisistory.com。
Thank you, Dominic. Thank you, everyone for listening. And let's say goodbye with the National Anthem of Brazil. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Hi, don't know the rest of the world of democracy, Gigantia, giant in a country of democracy
谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。让我们以巴西国歌作为告别。再见。再见。嗨，不知道民主的其余世界，Gigantia，民主国家的巨人
Hi everybody, it's Dominic Sandbrook here. There are two weeks to go, until the rest is history's inaugural festival at Hampton Court Palace. And frankly, I could not be more excited. There's going to be medieval combat. There are going to be all sorts of big-name historians. You can go to the palace. You can feast like Henry VIII on the very lawns where he walked.
大家好，我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。距离“历史的其余部分”在汉普顿宫举办的首届艺术节还有两周时间。坦率地说，我感到无比兴奋。届时将有中世纪的格斗表演。会有各种大牌历史学家。你可以去宫殿。你可以在亨利八世曾经走过的草坪上像他一样享用盛宴。
In the sunshine, I'll be talking to Tracy Bournemon about the Tudors. I'll be talking to Katia Hoyer about Vimar Germany. I'll be talking to Ian Hislop about the history of satire. So it's on two days. It's on Saturday the 4th of July and Sunday the 5th of July. The bad news is we have actually sold out the allocations that we were given by Hampton Court for both days. The good news, however, we have persuaded Hampton Court to let us have more people. So there will be a handful of extra tickets available for both the Saturday and the Sunday.
在阳光下，我将与特雷西·博内蒙（Tracy Borman）谈论都铎王朝。我将与卡蒂亚·霍耶（Katia Hoyer）谈论魏玛德国。我将与伊恩·希斯洛普（Ian Hislop）谈论讽刺的历史。所以活动为期两天。是在7月4日星期六和7月5日星期日。坏消息是，我们实际上已经卖光了汉普顿宫给我们的两天门票配额。然而，好消息是，我们已经说服汉普顿宫让我们增加人数。所以周六和周日都会有少量的额外门票。
Now, we do expect all of those extra tickets to sell out really quickly, so please do not wait to get your hands on them. The tickets are exclusive for club members. It's one of the benefits of being a member of the Restis History Club. Frankly, if you're not a member and you would like to go to the festival, the only way to do that is by joining the club. So you have to head to the Restis History.com to sign up. And then you go to the members area once you've signed up
现在，我们预计所有这些额外门票会很快售罄，所以请不要等待，尽快抢购。这些门票是俱乐部会员专享的。这是成为“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员的好处之一。坦率地说，如果你不是会员，又想参加艺术节，唯一的办法就是加入俱乐部。所以你必须前往therestisistory.com注册。注册后，你进入会员区
and you select a festival to get your tickets. We are really hoping to see as many of you there as possible in the sunshine, a Hampton court. Bye-bye. 150 years ago, they were hunting us down to kill us. and now they're hunting down immigrants to deport them. This is First America, the true story of how the United States came to be, and how we got to this present moment.
然后选择艺术节来获取你的门票。我们真的希望在汉普顿宫的阳光下尽可能多地见到你们。再见。150年前，他们追捕我们是为了杀死我们，而现在他们追捕移民是为了驱逐他们。这就是《第一美国》，关于美国是如何形成的，以及我们是如何走到今天这一刻的真实故事。
Listen to First America wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在任何你获取播客的地方收听《第一美国》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。